Này nhân sáng bắt đầu sửa bài đi hát kim.
Các em là một bạn báo cáo hay là các
thành viên đều tham gia bạn nào báo cáo
phần bạn đó.
Em chào cô,
em đại diện nhóm 6 thì bữa hôm nay tụi em
sẽ có một người trình bày ạ.
Ừ, để bạn đã xem màn trình bày đi.
Dạ em xe file lên trước ạ.
Nhạc của các bạn thấy được màn hình.
Còn thấy rồi, mình bắt đầu đi hết em.
Dạ, chào cô,
cho các bạn em đại diện nhóm 6 hôm nay em
trình bày về khảo sát kiến trúc hạ tầng
công nghệ thông tin của công ty giao hàng
nhanh theo khung tham chiếu năm lớp năng
lực. Hiện tại, nhóm em.
Đang có 12 người và hôm nay em là tài,
em sẽ đại diện nhóm 6 để thuyết trình sửa
bài tập hôm nay.
Nội dung trình bày của em thì hôm nay em
sẽ có 6 phần,
đầu tiên em sẽ giới thiệu về công ty và
khung tham chiếu năng lực ứng với công ty
Giao Hoàng Nhanh.
Tổng quan của nó năm lớp năng lực ứng với.
Từng công nghệ ở trong cái lớp năng lực
đó và kết luận ở trong cái lớp năng lực
này,
nó sẽ có những cái thứ gì và tầm quan
trọng nó như thế nào thì đầu tiên em
trình bày với các bạn là nhà hàng nhanh
là ai thì hiện tại nhà hàng nhanh là.
Là một trong những công ty logistics ở
tại Việt Nam và công ty này được thành
lập vào năm 2012 do anh Lương Duy Hoài
thành lập thì nhiệm vụ của Giao hàng
Nhanh là.
Kinh doanh trong mảng lĩnh vực về
Scommerce và logistics thì.
Nếu như mà mọi người di chuyển ngoài
đường thì sẽ thường xuyên thấy về ông nhà
hàng nhanh này thì cạnh tranh với ông nhà
hàng nhanh thì trực tiếp thì sẽ có 3 đối
thủ thường xuyên có mặt.
Đó là shopsy Express Zintee và Viettel
Post.
Ngoài ra sẽ có thêm nhiều đối thủ bên
ngoài khác,
thí dụ như là Bettercress hoặc là những
công ty Lasit nhỏ hơn,
nhưng nhìn chung về.
Thị trường thị sẽ có 3 ông này,
4 ông này là.
Ở ngoài thị trường,
mọi người sẽ dễ dàng bắt gặp thì.
Với cái hành trình phát triển của giao
hàng nhanh thì và khai khai công 12 thì
thành lập và đặt nền bóng đầu tiên thì.
Sau đó thì vào 2015 thì giao hàng nhanh
có làm theo một mảng nữa là amu có nghĩa
là giao hàng tức thời,
sau đó là 2019 có một cái hệ thống phân
loại đầu tiên.
Và 2023
Tài lộc kho trung chuyển tại Xuyên Á,
Long An và 2025 gần đây thì có thành là
một cái kho giao hàng lớn nhất tại Việt
Nam đó là ở kho Hưng Yên ở ngoài Bắc.
Và đây là những chuỗi mắt xích về chuỗi
giao nhận của sàn nhanh.
Mọi người có thể dễ dàng nhận thấy ở
ngoài đường về kho trung chuyển,
về xe tải, về shipper.
Đây là những hình ảnh rất là quen thuộc ở
phía ngoài.
Rồi về cái hạ tầng vật lý trong thực tế
thì mọi người cứ nhìn thấy ở đây đây là
rất là nhiều cái bao tải rồi đơn vận rồi
xe tải.
Ở trong cái mô hình này.
Rồi em nói sơ về lý do tại sao mà bên em
chọn giao hàng nhanh tại vì?
Ở trong giai đoạn nhanh và logistics nói
chung thì về công nghệ sẽ ứng dụng rất là
nhiều so với năm lớp năng lực tham chiếu.
Mọi người cứ hình dung là khi mà mình đặt
một cái đơn hàng ở trên Shopee hoặc là
TikTok Shop thì.
Làm sao để mà cái đơn hàng đó có thể vận
chuyển về đến tay của mình được?
Nó sẽ qua rất là nhiều lớp trước khi mà
nó về tay mình được.
Đầu tiên là khi mình đặt hàng thì shop
phải tạo mã đơn,
mã đơn xong rồi shipper đến lấy.
Rồi nó phải mới ra được mua cục,
mua cục xong rồi mới có xe tải,
xe tải xong rồi lại đi ra kho,
một cái kho tập kết bự và kho đó nó mới
luân chuyển về phía trong miền Nam của
mình.
Và đi theo xe tải theo shipper và tới
người nhận thì tất cả 9 bước mọi người
thấy ở đây thì.
Nó sẽ rất là nhiều về mặt kết nối hạ tầng,
về công nghệ,
ứng dụng trong đây để nó hoàn thành được
với một cái đơn hàng như vậy để đến tay
được người tiêu dùng.
Đây là độ phủ mạng lưới của giao hàng
nhanh và mọi người thấy khoảng 1.
500 mô cục rải trên cả nước và với mật độ
rất dày đặc.
Thì để đáp ứng được một hạ tầng dày đặc
như vậy thì.
Trong năm lớp năng lực tham chiếu thì cho
Hoàng Anh đã làm như thế nào để có thể
kết nối được một cái hạ tầng dày đặc như
thế này?
Rồi em nói về vai trò của giao hàng nhanh
thì đầu tiên với xã hội thì giao hàng
nhanh với một cái mật độ bố cục dày đặc
như mọi người vừa thấy thì đóng góp.
Với xã hội, tất nhiên,
một phần đầu tiên là tạo khoa việc làm
cho một số lượng lớn người ở trên cả nước.
Đầu tiên cái thứ 2 là có giao hàng nhanh
thì.
Sẽ đáp ứng một phần về một cái phát triển
về thương mại điện tử.
Hiện tại mọi người cũng đã thấy là
livestream với lại thương mại điện tử là
phát triển rất nhanh.
Thì em giao hàng nhanh này.
Nói riêng và logistics cơ mệt nói chung
đang góp một phần rất là lớn để một cái
gói hàng từ ngoài Hà Nội chỉ trong vòng
một tới 2 ngày có thể đến được tay người
tiêu dùng ở trong miền nam.
Và rất là nhanh.
Rồi với công nghệ thì ứng dụng những cái
công nghệ ở bên trong như là nhanh sẽ có
những cái công nghệ phân loại tự động nè,
sẽ có những cái API.
Những cái ứng dụng để mà shipper họ sử
dụng và những cái luồng vận hành theo dữ
liệu thời gian thực để góp phần phát
triển ở trong cái ngành công nghệ này.
À cái phần này thì nó khử trùng với cái ý
vừa trước thì ở trong cái phần công nghệ
giao hàng nhanh,
nó sẽ có gì thì cái sai này em sẽ làm dư
nên là em xin phép em bỏ qua.
Nhưng là kế tiếp em sẽ đi sâu về 5 lớp
năng lực với một cái khái niệm sơ về 5
lớp năng lực này và vai trò của nó ở
trong giai đoạn nhanh, nó sẽ như thế nào?
Đầu tiên thì mọi người sẽ thấy là với cái
skurity và.
Để NPT thì nó sẽ bao trùm cả 4 lớp năng
lực còn lại vì đây là một cái lớp bảo mật
và đăng nhập hệ thống nên là nó sẽ bao
phủ hết cả 4 lớp năng lực còn lại.
Đầu tiên về combuild và internet TVT thì
lớp này là gì?
Lớp này là một cái lớp máy chủ vật lý cố
định tại một nơi nào đó có thể là tại
histop fit,
có thể là tại một cái data center.
Cũng có thể là tại một nơi kho bãi nào đó
của nhà hàng nhanh thì cái vai trò này
đóng.
Đóng cái vai trò là một cái thấp thiết bị
vật lý để vận hành những.
Kết nối trung tâm,
ví dụ như là shipper thì cũng phải có
điện thoại để sử dụng kết nối về hệ thống
hoặc là máy chủ thì nó cũng phải có lớp
vật lý có sebu,
có ram để vận hành được hệ thống.
Thì.
Nếu như mà thiếu cái lớp này á thì toàn
bộ hệ thống sẽ ngay lập tức là downtime
sẽ không vận hành được gì hết tại vì nó
không có một cái lớp,
không có một cái siburam gì để mà.
Xử lý được.
Rồi
Kế tiếp là ở trong cái lớp Combie and
Class PT này thì nó sẽ bao gồm là phần
cứng, phần mềm mạng, quản trị và bảo mật.
Thì em đi sơ qua về khái niệm của nó với
phần mềm,
phần cứng thì em vừa có trình bày rồi thì
với phần mềm.
Phần mềm tương ứng với lại cái lớp phần
cứng. Nó sẽ bao gồm là Windows nè,
Linus nè, nó sẽ có ảo hóa,
ảo hóa thì mọi người sẽ thấy được nhiều
cái về Vinwear hoặc là so.
Rốc móc hoặc là Open Stack sẽ có những
cái nhiều cái ứng dụng ở ngoài thị trường
và về mạng, kết nối mạng của nó,
nó sẽ bao gồm.
Vậy Lan thì Lan thì.
Với công ty thì làm sao để mà từ một cái
hệ thống máy chủ đặt ở một nơi nào đó,
ví dụ như data center có thể truyền được
dữ liệu tới một cái bưu cục cố định?
Như trong cái bản đồ mà 1.
500 một cục hồi nãy,
mọi người vừa thấy thì nó phải có nhiều
cái thành phần phối hợp với nhau về LAN ở
trung tâm và nó được đẩy ra one ở ngoài
internet thuê bao kênh.
Và nó đẩy về được lan ở trong vô cục.
À, về mặt quản trị thì.
Ở trong ngân hàng nhanh thì sẽ có rất
nhiều.
Cấu hình cho từng vô cục với 2.
500 mô cục mà mọi người vừa ra 1.
500 bô cục mà người vừa thấy á,
thì tất nhiên là sẽ có 1.
500 cái thiết bị mạng được đặt.
Tương ứng với số lượng đó thì làm sao
người quản trị có thể cấu hình được?
1.
500 ông này bằng tay thì nó là một cái
bài toán phải giải và nó sẽ là dùng
ansible hoặc là một cái công cụ nào đó để
mình apply cấu hình xuống để khi mà một
cái điểm mới.
Nó đóng vào một cái điểm khác,
nó mở ra thì đã có một cái cấu hình để mà
mình apply xuống hàng loạt rồi thì không
có phải cần cấu hình tây nó như một ông
mà cần phải đi cấu hình tây từng vô cục á
thì không thể nào mà cấu hình nổi.
Và tương ứng cái lớp đó thì sẽ là.
Phần bảo mật ở trong một cái bưu cục mà
nếu như mà nhiều ông xài chung một cái
mạng với nhau á mà không có một cái phần
bảo vệ ở trong máy tính thì khi.
Đó các máy tính nó sẽ bị lây lan mã độc
với nhau là nó làm.
Tắc nghẽn một phần ở trong mô cục và gây
ảnh hưởng tới vận hành của kho.
Ở đây là em trình bày sơ qua về những cái
công nghệ và những cái hình ảnh tham khảo,
ứng với lại từng lớp năng lực.
Mọi người sẽ thấy ở đây nó sẽ có nhiều
hãng và.
À,
hình ảnh tham khảo của những cái hãng đó
ở đây.
Rồi tiếp theo đi về ốp platform thì bộ
công cụ này dùng để.
Ờ tạo ra một cái quy trình để một cái đội
tập trung có thể.
Ở một nơi cố định nhưng mà có thể vận
hành được trên toàn quốc thì nếu như mà
không có cái vai trò này á thì.
Ở không thể nào biết được là tối ưu vận
hành nó như thế nào và ở ngoài kia đang
bị sự cố gì hoặc là đang cần phải tối ưu
một cái.
Công việc nào đó cụ thể,
ví dụ như là một con IT ở tại trụ sở đi
thì làm sao ông biết được là ở ngoài kia
có bao nhiêu bưu cục đang bị mất kết nối?
Vào mùa mưa lũ ở miền trung thì tất nhiên
là mưa lũ hoặc là thiên tai lũ lụt sẽ rất
là nhiều thì lúc đó vô cục họ sẽ bị đau
tham rất là nhiều thì làm sao?
Có thể đứng ở từ xa mà quan sát được biết
được là cái bưu cục đó nó có.
Sự cố gì hay không thì đó là cái vai trò
của Oploatform.
Đóng góp cho cái mô hình tham chiếu này.
Ở đây thì tương ứng với phần cứng,
phần mềm mạng quản trị và bảo mật,
em đi sơ qua về đầu tiên là về phần cứng
thì cái phần asian này nó sẽ là một lớp
combuild giống như là một cái máy ảo,
nó chạy ở trên nền.
Cứng của cái lớp một nên là phần này cũng
không có gì để đáng nói em đi qua về phần
mềm.
Thì với phần mềm thì nó sẽ bao gồm những
cái tool quản trị về monitoring hoặc là
về backhup hoặc là về automation thì.
Monitorine nó là gì?
Như em vừa nói là làm sao để mà quan sát
được từ xa thì với monitorine ở trong hệ
thống.
Nó sẽ có công nghệ về một.
Ứng dụng Pro Mediat và Rafana thì 2 ông
này sẽ đóng vai trò là lấy.
Ở tất cả những cái thông tin cơ sở ở máy
chủ máy trạm hoặc là những cái IBO ở phía
ngoài internet,
nó có đang bị down time hay không,
nó đang có binh tới được hay không?
Thì robitus sẽ đóng vai trò là.
Monitorin cho toàn bộ những lớp thiết bị
này và Rafana sẽ đóng vai trò là diễn
giải dữ liệu ra để cho mình thấy được là
với 1.
500 mưu cục kia thì đang có bao nhiêu ông
là rớt mạng.
Và đang có bao nhiêu không là đang vận
hành được?
Và tương ứng đó,
nếu như mà lớp một mình có máy chủ và máy
ảo thì tất nhiên là trên máy chủ của máy
ảo đó sẽ có backup.
Tại vì khi mà máy chủ máy ảo bị down time
bị hư một cái thiết bị ổ cứng đi thì nó
sẽ kéo theo việc là bị mất dữ liệu mà mất
dữ liệu thì sẽ bị down time rất là nặng.
Thì tất nhiên là phải có một cái gym
backup để sao chép cái dữ liệu đó kịp
thời để khi mà có sự cố thì trong vòng
đâu đó 15 hoặc là 20 phút thôi thì có thể
mình khôi phục lên lại được.
Định không bị gián đoạn tới hệ thống.
À
Ngoài ra thì.
Ở phần blog mạng thì ờm.
Em nói sơ về cái phần về.
Telemiti thì với nhiều vua cục thì làm
sao để mà.
Có một cái điểm để mà mình tập trung được
toàn bộ cái lock của toàn bộ cái bưu cục
đó để mà mình xem được là cái ông bưu cục
này hôm nay ông vận hành như thế nào,
cái data ông gửi lên như thế nào?
Thì cái bài toán cấp ca với elite shirt,
nó giải quyết các vai trò là chỉ có nếu
như mà chỉ không có cak ca ở đây nha mà
chỉ có aliist search thôi thì với 1.
500 mua cục kia.
Mà gửi lên đồng thời á thì khả năng cao
là cái ông lên sếp này sẽ không nhận nổi
tại vì nó quá nhiều đi.
Thì lúc đó sẽ có một cái ông cấp ca ông
đứng ở giữa để mà ông.
Cho những ông này,
những ông bố cục này vô một cái hàng đợi
để ông nào tới trước thì vô trước,
ông nào tới sau thì vui lòng đợi một vài
giây xong rồi ông sẽ gửi vào cái hệ thống
tra cứu này để khi đó có một cái đội tập
trung ở trong này họ sẽ.
Xem được cái lóc vận hành của những cái
ông bưu cục.
Rồi rồi tiếp theo về quản trị quản trị
thì ở trong cái vùng sự cố á thì nó sẽ có
một cái vòng đời và một cái sự cố như thế
này để.
Có những cái bài học khi mà có sự cố thì
phải có người tuân theo những cái quy
trình như thế này và.
Ghi nhận lại trên hệ thống để.
Để khi mà có sự cố tiếp theo xảy ra á thì
mình sẽ rút được kinh nghiệm và có những
cái bài học trước đó mà mình không bị.
Mắc phải nữa thì đây là một cái quy trình
để quản lý sự cố và đồng thời với IT thì
cũng phải có một cái SI cam kết là không
được downtime trong.
Bao nhiêu tiếng trong một tháng,
chẳng hạn đó là những cái.
Cam kết về quản trị đối với IT.
À.
Về phần bảo mật này thì nó sẽ tương tự
như là cái phần bảo mật ở lớp 1 nên là em
cũng không có nhắc gì để tới tiếp theo là
về.
Đây là những cái công nghệ mà ứng dụng ở
trong cái lớp 2,
mọi người có thể xem sơ qua.
Rồi tiếp theo về Security và NDT thì lớp
này là gì?
Lớp này nó kiểm soát ai được ra vào hệ
thống và bảo mật tới đâu,
mọi người cứ hình dung là mình là một
nhân viên mới, mình vào công ty.
Thì ai cấp quyền cho mình vào,
đội IT phải cấp quyền cho mình một cái
account đúng không?
Xong rồi mình locking vô được locking vô
cũng chưa xong nữa.
Llocking cũng phải có quyền ở trong đó.
Thì cái vai trò của segurity và nitiity
này là xác định xem bạn là ai và bạn được
phép truy cập tới đâu.
Nếu như mà không có lớp này thì toàn bộ
dữ liệu và hệ thống nó bị lộ ra ngoài hết
và bất kỳ ai cũng có thể vô coi được thì
nó là một cái điều không cho phép ở trong
doanh nghiệp.
Thì đầu tiên về cái lớp phần cứng,
phần cứng ở đây là security.
Nó sẽ có ít phần cứng chuyên biệt ở cái
phần, cái chiều phần cứng này.
Đa số thì hiện tại bây giờ người ta sẽ sử
dụng một vài thiết bị.
Chị giống như là sofast hoặc là balo into.
Nhưng mà những đặc thù của những thiết bị
phần cứng nó,
nó rất là mắc tiền và ít có công ty nào
có thể đủ khả năng để trang bị được.
Ở cái lớp phần cứng này nên thường người
ta sẽ sử dụng những cái oblication ở trên
web là chính,
ví dụ như là Wap của Clair hoặc là những
cái ứng dụng về Security mà có thể.
Chặn ở cái tầng application trước.
Còn cái phần phần cứng này sẽ ít có công
ty nào có đủ khả năng để triển khai được?
Rồi tiếp theo là về lớp software,
software thì em sẽ có bóc tách ra làm 2
phần chính ở trong này.
Đầu tiên là về lớp danh tính tập trung nó
là AM.
Thì anh em này nó.
Phụ trách một cái công việc là với một
người vừa vô thì ATM này nó sẽ cung cấp
danh tính là bạn được vô hệ thống nào?
Bạn được vô 1, 2, 3, 4 hệ thống ở đây.
Thì sau khi mà.
Cái ông đó nghỉ việc thì IT không thể nào
mà tìm tới đúng cái 4 hệ thống này để mà
gỡ cái ông nghỉ việc này ra được,
nó sẽ rất là mất thời gian và không thể
nào tìm nổi với nếu như mà quy mô công ty
nó đâu đó 1.000 người hoặc là 10.
000 người chẳng hạn.
Thủy cảm thấy là từ.
Từng một cái ứng dụng mà đi vô trong đó
mà gỡ từng người ra được thì nó sẽ có một
cái chỗ để quản lý danh tính tập trung.
Để khi mà cấp quyền thì mình chỉ cần đứng
trên đúng cái danh tính tập trung đó để
mình cấp thôi.
Và cái người nghỉ việc đó.
Khi mà out rồi thì mình chỉ vô mình gỡ họ
là coi như toàn bộ hệ thống.
Xém,
họ sẽ mất quyền hết một cái ứng dụng mà
mọi người có thể dễ dàng thấy nhất đó là
Google SO.
Đó là một cái.
Thường xuyên thấy ở phía bên ngoài.
Ở kế tiếp, phần thứ 2, ngoài a game đó là.
EDR EDR này nó là một phần về bảo mật
được cài hẳn ở trên máy của user thì khi
mà user họ.
Vô tình đau một cái file virus hay là đau
họ bật một cái gì đó bị phái sinh chẳng
hạn một một cái phần mềm bị giả mạo bị
lừa đảo đi thì sẽ có một cái proset,
một cái tiến trình ở trên.
Máy trạm nó bắt được cái mã đồng này và
nó.
Cô lập cái mã độc đó để không để lây lan
ở trong cái hệ thống nội bộ của công ty
và sẽ đẩy ra một cái thông báo tập trung.
Để nhắc cho đội IT biết là ông này đang
bị tấn công và vui lòng kiểm tra ngay lập
tức.
À em bị ghi tiếp về phần mạng thì phần
mạng ở đây nó sẽ có tiêu biểu,
nhất là về VPN và Zero Trust thì với nó
chỉ có một cái.
Phân biệt dễ dàng thôi là với những cái
vivent kiểu cũ thì.
Sẽ không có phân quyền được rõ ràng là
kiểm tra được là ai đi tới những hệ thống
nào thì những năm gần đây thịnh hành về
một cái loại gọi là zero chết thì mọi
người có thể dễ dàng bắt gặp được cái
khái niệm này.
Ở trên lafre,
nó gọi là zero chết hoặc le thì nó sẽ có
nhiều cái polici ở trên đó để phân quyền
được cụ thể là với cái account đó thì chỉ
có quyền truy cập được đến những cái hệ
thống nào cố định.
Nó sẽ không đi được lung tung.
À
Thì đó là cái phần về VBN.
Về phần bảo mật thì cái lớp này nó đã bao
trùm hết tất cả cái lớp còn lại rồi.
Đây là những cái công nghệ hoạt động ở
trên cái lớp năng lực security và Denity
này, mọi người có thể tham khảo qua.
Em đi tiếp về lớp 4,
lớp 4 ở đây là account và tích hợp.
Thì lớp này đóng vai trò là gì?
Với một cái hệ thống tích hợp platform
như thế này thì ở.
Ví dụ như là giao hàng nhanh,
có một cái tạo mã đơn để dành riêng cho
các shop và các.
Kho trung chuyển ở phía ngoài thì khi mà
tôi đang đóng vai trò là một người bán
hàng,
đi thì tôi muốn tạo một cái mã vận đơn
nhanh để mà.
Tôi giao một cái đơn về điện thoại đi
giao cho một cái ông mua hàng thì tôi
không thể nào mà bán 10 cái điện thoại
thì mang 10 cái điện thoại ra ngoài bố
cục để mà tạo hóa đơn cho 10 cái điện
thoại đó xong rồi đóng hàng ngoài vô cục
xong mới gửi đi.
Và lần nào cũng lặp lại như vậy thì nó sẽ
rất là mất thời gian nên giao hàng nhanh
sẽ tạo ra một lớp IBI để tạo tự tạo hóa
đơn thì khi đó.
Tôi là một người chủ shop máy điện thoại
thì chỉ cần lên app của vàng nhanh và
đăng ký tài khoản đăng nhập vô,
bấm tạo mã đơn thì nó sẽ tự động nó sinh
ra một cái mã đơn.
Trực tiếp ngay tại shop của tôi thì tôi
chỉ cần.
À, đóng đơn và gửi đi thôi,
đó là một cái vai trò về tích hợp
platform thì.
Nhìn chung về cái lớp năng lực áp và lần
tích hợp này thì phần cứng nó cũng sẽ.
Xài chung với lại lớp năng lực thứ nhất,
ngoài ra là cái app,
cái phần cứng và cái phần mềm ở cái lớp
năng lực 4 này,
nó sẽ có một cái tính liên quan với nhau.
Đó là về mặt.
Ở tăng giảm scale cho hệ thống,
ví dụ như là với phần cứng thì.
Một phần cứng có một cái CU cố định và
RAM cố định là 12 con và 8 GB thì nó chỉ
chịu được đâu đó khoảng 1 triệu rewet
chẳng hạn. Tôi ví dụ là vậy thì.
Khi mà đơn hàng tăng lên 2 triệu thì sao?
Tăng lên 3 triệu thì sao thì cái phần
cứng nó sẽ chịu không nổi và khi mà chịu
không nổi thì sẽ treo và nó nghẽn thì.
Lúc đó sẽ có một cái vai trò đứng ở đây.
Nó là phần mềm là cao 8m,
cao 8m ở đây nó đóng vai trò là.
Tự động để scale cái hệ thống của mình
lên, nó là một cái.
Tính năng của Google phát phát minh phát
triển ra thì khi một cái lương một cái
mùi event như là.
Vừa rồi 8 tháng 8 đi chẳng hạn thì đơn
hàng nó lên đâu đó khoảng 10 triệu đơn đi
thì.
Cái hệ thống catime này nó mới sinh ra
một cái.
Nhiều tỉnh sinh thêm nhiều xe bu và ram
để mà ghi nhận với 10 triệu đơn đó để xử
lý,
nhưng mà khi mà 10 triệu đơn như vậy thì
qua 10 event thì vận hành với.
Cái cấu hình đó thì nó sẽ là lãng phí thì
lúc đó internet sẽ nhận thấy là à ngày
bình thường tôi sẽ không có nhiều đơn.
Tới như vậy thì hệ thống cũng sẽ tự giảm
bớt lại cái lưu lượng của suppu và ram để
cho thích hợp những cái ngày bình thường
họ vận hành để tránh gây lãng phí cho hệ
thống.
Ừ.
Về tầng mạng và CICD ở đây và bảo mật em
sẽ nói chung là với cái tầng 4 này thì.
Vậy rút tin nội bộ của nó,
nó sẽ bao gồm rất phức tạp ở một cái lượt
gọi API,
API nó sẽ gọi qua một cái lớp bảo mật,
đứng chặn giống như một cái cửa mình gọi
đó là engress.
Thì Interest ở đây,
nó sẽ đẩy qua một cái lớp kiểm soát lưu
lượng và nó định tuyến, định tuyến,
nó sẽ đẩy vào trong catamet để nó catamet.
Nó chỉ định là cái ông API này nó đang
thuộc.
Cái dịch vụ gì ở trong catamet để mà chỉ
định đúng vào cái dịch vụ thì ở trong
catamet này sẽ có rất là nhiều dịch vụ ở
trong này,
nó sẽ có dịch vụ về vận chuyển đơn nè,
dịch vụ về kiểm tra thông tin tài xế nè.
Kiểm tra mã đơn hàng rồi kiểm tra những
cái đơn về đền bù,
thất thoát xem là cái tiến độ của nó tới
đâu rồi thì.
Ở trong cái lượt API này,
nó sẽ chỉ đích đến cụ thể là như vậy.
Chết rồi, còn sâu về xuống.
Phía bên dưới thì cái phần quản trị.
Nó sẽ.
Liên quan gì về tới những anh lập trình
viên khi mà một cái hệ thống được?
Ra một cái tính năng mới đi thì cái người
IT hồi xưa thì họ phải tự thiết lập lại
môi trường xong rồi test test xong rồi
mới đẩy lên reaction thì lần nào.
Tẩy lên một cái tính năng mới như vậy
cũng phải lặp đi lặp lại từng bước như
vậy thì nó gây.
Rất là nhiều lãng phí về nguồn nhân lực
và.
Ở không có người nào có thể làm được
ngoài cái việc đó nên nó sẽ có một cái
phần quản trị về CICD hay còn gọi là cụ
thể nó là viết club CI hoặc là Ago CD thì.
Cái lớp này nó đóng vai trò như là.
Tự kiểm thử ra.
Ờ trình có gì cần ấy hả?
Rồi em nói tiếp về DeepbCI và Ago City
thì cái giflab CI và GoCD này nó sẽ đóng
vai trò như là một cái bảng triển khai tự
động.
Thì cái ông IT,
ông không cần phải tự tạo môi trường.
Ông không cần phải tự điệp lôi có,
ông kiểm thử xong rồi mới điệp lôi đồ
option được mà Georgies và Gocide này
đóng vai trò từ A tới Z.
Và
Chỉ cần mình làm đúng một cái version đầu
thôi, tất cả những cái version sau,
nó sẽ cứ lặp đi lặp lại với giống như một
cái version đầu để tránh lãng phí tài
nguyên, theo dõi.
Em nói đi tiếp về data plugform thì với
datablatform này,
nó là một cái nguồn đối với nhiều công ty
thì datablatform nó là một cái mạch máu
sống của công ty.
Thì dữ liệu nó là quan trọng nhất,
không gì quan trọng bằng dữ liệu thì đây
là một cái nơi để mà định nghĩa data
labform xem là dữ liệu được luôn ở đâu và
ai được khai thác dữ liệu đó.
Có những cái dữ liệu nó rất là nhạy cảm,
ví dụ như là siêu đuôi,
siêu đi để đối soát dòng tiền hoặc là về
mã đơn hàng.
Thông tin đơn hàng đang được gửi đi như
thế nào thì mọi người sẽ.
Hay đọc ở trên báo trên mạng,
nhìn thấy có những cái việc là tại sao
tôi đọc một cái đơn hàng nhưng mà cái đơn
đó của tôi nó chưa được tới.
Ở trên hệ thống thì nó chưa nó chưa giao
tới,
nhưng mà tự nhiên có một cái ông nào đó
chạy tới nhà tôi và kêu anh ơi,
anh có cái đơn này nè,
anh nhận đi anh chuyển tiền và mình cũng
không kiểm tra nữa. Mình để đi,
mình nhận cái đơn đó xong mình mới mở ra
mình thấy bên trong à.
Nó chỉ có một cục đá thôi.
Thì mấy ngày sau xong cái đơn của mình,
cái đơn thiệt của mình nó mới tới rồi lúc
đó mình mới ủa cái đơn này tôi đặt mà tại
sao có một một bên khác họ giao tới trước
mà giao lừa đảo nữa.
Thì đó là hậu quả của việc thất thoát dữ
liệu.
Phải bị lộ dữ liệu ra thì mới bị lừa đảo
như vậy thì đó là một cái ví dụ về cái
tầm điểm nhấn của data labform.
Thì ở trong da tăng platform này nó sẽ có.
Những cái lớp công nghệ,
thí dụ như là Boss Re SQL hoặc là Mongo
DBSQL thì.
Tài ơi, chúng đang bị tắt mít.
À dạ.
Ở nhà đa tablatform thì em nói lại về
phần mềm thì ở trong cái lớp này nó sẽ có
nhiều cái.
Ứng dụng về SUL ở trong này,
nó sẽ có về vote RSUL hoặc là Mongo SUL
hoặc là Masu.
Nó sẽ có rất là nhiều và tùy những cái
kịch bản lưu trữ.
Cái dữ liệu đó như thế nào thì cái người
vận hành hệ thống sẽ lưu trữ cái.
Dữ liệu đó trên cái nền tảng đó,
ví dụ như là về mã vận đơn thì.
Chắc chắn là sẽ dùng những cái SQL như là
Borgy hoặc là Mongo để đó là những cái
SPL.
Nó thuộc về cơ sở dữ liệu không quan hệ.
Nó khác với lại mã QL thì lúc đó truy cứu
và truy xuất.
Cái điều đó sẽ nhanh hơn là MSBL,
nhưng mà sẽ có những cái.
Dữ liệu nó cần phải phối hợp với nhau và
quan hệ,
nó cần phải có framury key và second key
thì lúc đó thì cái người thiết lập cái
data loc phải không lại quay về câu
chuyện là lưu trữ cái dữ liệu đó ở trên
Malaysia.
Và
Ở.
Ở trong mát video này thì.
Nó sẽ có về phần mạng và quản trị và bảo
mật em sẽ gom vào nói chung,
đó là 3 thứ này lúc nào cũng phải đi song
song với nhau để có một cái.
Khi kiểm soát truy cập nó.
Bảo mật như em vừa nói là nếu như mà.
Anh làm data nhưng mà anh cái đường mạng
của anh cái dữ liệu data đó lại để bút
tích ra phía bên ngoài và ai cũng có thể
truy cập được cái data đó thì đó là điều
không được phép.
Và cái người quản trị thì phải tuân theo
cái bộ quy tắc để.
Cái bảng đó có chứa gì và ai được phép
truy cập vào được lấy từ nguồn nào?
Và bảo mật là.
Truy xuất lại cái dấu vết của thông tin
nên là data nó đã bị truy xuất vô thì ai
là người truy xuất?
Và cái nhật ký truy cập của cái người đó
đó đang làm đâu để mình lấy ra được đúng
về cái?
Data.
Thì.
Với các thầu vốn ngành chuyển phát này
thì ứng với 5 lớp năng lực này thì.
Rất là sâu sắc về năm lớp bất kỳ một lớp
nào ở trong năm lớp năng lượng này thiếu
thì cũng sẽ làm gián đoạn vận hành hệ
thống của giao hàng nhanh.
Bởi vì giao hàng nhanh ứng dụng.
Cái lượng đơn theo mùa tùy theo có thể là
tháng hai nghỉ Tết thì đơn hàng nó sẽ ít
thì cái hệ thống nó sẽ không cần phải
scale lên quá cao,
nhưng mà nếu như mà vào những cái tháng
như là tháng 11 và tháng 12 và tháng một.
Gần tết thì.
Những cái lớp ứng dụng này tương tác với
nhau bằng một cách rất là chặt chẽ.
Bởi vì khi mà có sự cố một lớp có vấn đề
thôi thì sẽ kéo theo toàn bộ hạ tầng.
Họ sẽ có vấn đề.
Và ảnh hưởng tới vận hành rất là nhiều và.
Ở đây em xin kết luận bằng 5 ý ở bên dưới
và xin phép lại cái phần trình bày cũng
hơi dài dòng ở đây. **** mọi người và cô.
Cho thêm ý kiến ạ.
Cái em giữ cái slide ha cái phần này khi
back của bây giờ cô sửa bài thì cô cũng
nhắc lại cái yêu cầu bài tập của mình hôm
trước như cái bài tập yêu cầu hôm trước
của mình là mình sẽ tìm hiểu.
Kiến trúc hạ tầng công nghệ thông tin của
doanh nghiệp thông qua khung tham chiếu
về cái năm lớp năng lực để mình hiểu hơn,
rõ hơn về cái khái niệm các cái định
nghĩa quan trọng.
Vai trò cũng như là các đặc điểm kỹ thuật
hoặc là những cái thành phần thường được
sử dụng ở cái ở các cái được đầu tư ở các
lớp đó mà một cách tổng quát.
Và sau đó là mình đương nhiên là khi mà
sau ngày hôm nay là cô sẽ cập nhật danh
sách đề tài đầu án môn học thì sau khi
mình có đề tài rồi thì mình sẽ vô cụ thể
một trường học.
Thì cái phần bài tập tài liệu ngày hôm
nay,
nó có thể làm để là cái tài là lý thuyết
nền để cho các em tìm,
giống như ở đây bản được nhóm của bạn.
Tài thì có thấy đánh giá cao là cái phần
các em có tìm hiểu một số cái thành phần
thường được sử dụng và hay đầu tư ở một
cái vài lớp trong cái ngữ cảnh mà các em
đã chọn. Thì khi mà các em.
Nói chung trên đây,
khi mà các em đầu tư hoặc là các em phát
triển đầu tư hạ tầng phát triển á,
sử dụng cái thiết bị gì,
hoặc là sử dụng công nghệ gì,
hoặc là sử dụng cái ứng dụng nào đó thì
nó là một sự lựa chọn và sự lựa chọn đó
coi.
Mình sẽ xem xét làm sao cho nó hợp lý,
phù hợp với cái nhu cầu của doanh nghiệp
chứ nó không có một cái đáp án đúng chính
xác.
Và mình có thể tìm hiểu thêm tùy theo nhu
cầu, mục tiêu của cái bài ở đó là vậy.
Cái phần phần tìm hiểu của nhóm bạn tài
thì làm khá là ổn về cái phần tìm hiểu kỹ
nhưng mà khá là các em đã chọn vô một cái
ngữ cảnh ứng dụng cụ thể luôn rồi.
Thì ở đây là cô cho cô hỏi lại nè,
nhóm mình chọn cái ứng dụng này để các em
dễ.
Để miêu tả.
Hơn hay là nó là cái,
đây là cái đề tài mà nhớ mình chọn và các
em bắt đầu vô như cái đề tài mình tìm
hiểu luôn.
Ạ dạ,
tụi em đang trình bày ở trong cái ngữ
cảnh để cho mọi người có thể dễ hình dung
hơn á cô còn về cái đề tài thì tụi em
đang phân vân ở cái lớp 4 và lớp 5 chưa
có một cái.
Cụ thể, chưa chưa có chốt đồ khen cụ thể.
Để mấy cái thành phần thường được sử dụng
trong các lớp năng lực đầu tư được sử
dụng trong các lớp năng lực đó là các em
tìm hiểu theo kiểu khái quát thôi,
ví dụ giống như lớp số 1 hay.
Số 1 hay lớp số giống như lớp của em mà
lớp xuống số 5 thì thường sẽ thả sử dụng
các thành đầu tư,
các thành phần thiết bị cũng như các công
nghệ sử dụng các công nghệ đó.
Là tìm hiểu thôi hay là nó là cái thông
tin của cái doanh nghiệp mà các em đã
Dạ đúng rồi.
chọn?
Dạ, nó là tìm hiểu khái quát nữa cô.
Mà là người ta đang à anh tình yêu.
Dạ có nghĩa là ở trong cái ngành nghề này
thì ở trong cái lớp năng lực đó thì sẽ có
những cái công nghệ và người ta ứng dụng
nhiều ở những cái phần mềm này.
Thì sau đó rồi tụi em sẽ focus vô làm
đứng đặt ở một cái ngữ cảnh cụ thể luôn
là nó là bot re SQL hay là momo SQL?
Ok, vậy nếu vậy,
nếu mình thật sự cái bài này,
các em có thể đứng ở góc độ doanh nghiệp
chung để các em giới thiệu về các cái.
À,
về cái ý nghĩa của lớp năng lực ở tôi
thường được sử dụng trong cái quy trình
nào ở doanh nghiệp nói chung,
nó đóng vai trò gì và có các cái thành
phần có các thiết bị, các thành phần,
các công nghệ hay được sử dụng ở các lớp
năng lực này.
Mình giới thiệu tổng quát chung với là
được tại mục tiêu cái vai này là kiểu
tổng quát và các em sau này khi mà các em
định hình nó,
các cái thí dụ các thiết bị hoặc các công
nghệ hay được sử dụng ở các lớp rồi thì
các em có thể đi tìm hiểu thêm và mình
đưa ra sự lựa chọn phù hợp.
Cái đề xuất thuyết minh của mình.
Cái đề xuất thuyết minh là em đưa kế
hoạch đầu tư phát triển cho cơ sở tài
nguyên thông tin cho một cái doanh nghiệp,
nên mình sẽ là người đưa ra sự lựa chọn
và đưa ra cái giải pháp cho doanh nghiệp.
Và cho doanh nghiệp luôn nên lúc đó các
em cần có đưa ra sự lựa chọn quyết định
cụ thể và mình sẽ đầu tư cái gì và mình
đương nhiên là mình sẽ phải giải thích
cho người ta biết là tại sao phải dùng nó,
dùng nó có tốt không,
dùng nó đem lại lợi ích gì cho doanh
nghiệp để thuyết phục.
Cái nhà đầu tư người ta đồng ý với hầu dự
án này của mình nên đó là cái nhiệm vụ
của mình.
Còn còn lại là sự lựa chọn lựa chọn phù
hợp ha nên khi về phần này thì các nhóm
các bạn giới thiệu cũng.
Có được một vài các cái thành phần khá ổn
và một số cái thành phần thiết bị công
nghệ thông dụng kem có thể sử dụng để
tham khảo được,
nhưng mà cái phần bài tập á là cô không
có yêu cầu các em phải vô một cái ngữ
cảnh thí nghiệm nào cả ha.
Bạn vô một cái ngữ cảnh doanh nghiệp để
bạn dễ miêu tả hình dung hơn,
hoặc là nó là cái đề tài mà các em các
bạn đã chọn,
các bạn làm gần thì cũng được,
nhưng mà còn cái đối với các em làm bài
tập á thì nếu mình đã mình dựa vào phần
bài này mình sửa á thì.
Em chỉ cần hiểu cái lớp năng lực đó dùng
để làm gì và các thành phần thường sử
dụng thôi chứ không nhất thiết phải chọn
một cái doanh nghiệp cụ thể.
Sao nên.
Cô cho em hỏi cái lúc mà em thảo luận,
các bạn làm đề tài á của chị á thì có
phần data platform á thì đa số là.
Thích chưa đúng đến phần này bao giờ thì
nếu mà em không biết thì em có thể chọn 3
cái 4 cái trên vỏ phía dưới được không?
Và cái này là bác hồi cô sẽ nói trong cái
phần bức xương hướng dẫn đề tài và cái
bài tập tiếp theo của mình là cái phần để
cô cơ cái bài tập.
Có đặt tên chưa bài tập rồi.
Cô mở cái bài tập đó lên rồi mình sẽ làm
ra bài tập về nhà là bài tập đầy.
Xác định phạm vi đề xuất á. Lúc đó,
cô sẽ nói rõ và ở đây thì cô nói nhanh
luôn cho các em biết là.
Ờ mình chọn thôi,
các em phạm vi là do các em chọn.
Các loại thành mục tiêu của cái bài thực
hành với bài đồ án là để cho các em hình
dung tổng quan về cơ sở hạ tầng thông tin.
Và mình làm quen với các dự án.
Với cách thuyết minh và cái việc mà mình
viết đề xuất để xin kinh phí cho các dự
án thì bên tòa nhà thông tin mình đặc
trưng của nó là khi em phải đi xung phanh
thì theo dự án của mình để triển khai để
triển khai và từ phát triển cái hệ thống
của mình **** muốn.
Nên đây là công việc kỹ năng mà bắt buộc
mình sẽ phải rèn luyện nó trong thông qua
cái môn này cô cho cái em rèn luyện cái
đó và mình khi mà mình đi thi xác minh đề
xuất á thì mình cần phải nắm rõ là cái.
Cái thuyết minh đề xuất của mình phải hợp
lý, thống nhất.
Và nó phù hợp với nhu cầu hiện tại có áp
dụng công nghệ mới và thường thì cô hay
khuyến khích á là nếu mà các các nhóm mà
các em muốn đạt đỉnh cao á thì các em nên
đi tìm hiểu một số công nghệ mới nữa hoặc
hiện tại.
Tại cái mục tiêu của mình,
học kiến thức mới mà em và em biết cái
hiểu công nghệ đó là gì và biết cái ứng
dụng các công nghệ cho nó vào các lớp
năng lực này để cho cải thiện cái chức
năng hoàn thiện của các lớp năng lực đó
và làm cho cơ sở hạ tầng thông tin của
mình nó.
Đáp ứng nhu cầu của người dùng thì càng
tốt hơn.
Mục tiêu của mình là cái đó ha và nhưng
mà là đương nhiên là trong một cái dự án
lớn á,
cô khuyến khích cho các nhóm là không có
đầu tư hết năm lớn đâu em.
Đối với các cái nhóm thường thì cô.
Gợi ý là các em nên chọn từ 21 đến 2 3
lớp thôi,
đậu loại thôi chứ mình đừng nên chọn quá
nhiều,
chọn quá nhiều á thì cái phần kiến thức
tìm hiểu của các em nó sẽ bị loãng ra và
nó không có đi vô một.
Cái trọng tâm nào cả?
Ví dụ với lại ở đây thông qua cái phần mà
trình bày á thì các em cũng sẽ thấy là
cái lớp này nó phân.
Phân biệt ra để theo chức năng để cho kem
dễ hình dung khi nó vận hành thôi chứ nó
có những cái phần được tái sử dụng.
Thí dụ,
cái lớp phần cứng khi mà mình được đầu tư
hoàn thiện xong rồi thì nó có thể được sử
dụng ở nhiều lớp khác nhau.
Và nó sẽ được sử dụng thống nhất chứ nó
không phải là các cái thành phần cứng
hoặc là các thiết bị phần mềm một cách rờ
rạc.
Nó hoạt động một cách độc lập với nhau
đâu mà các cái thành phần này nó sẽ được
tận dụng và hỗ trợ lẫn nhau trong cái quá
trình vận hành.
Thế và khi cái hình dung là khi mà mình
ứng nghe các em nghe nói ứng dụng các
công nghệ như là ở trí tuệ nhân tạo thì
khi mà triển khai một cái dự án á là
người ta phải xác định ra cái một cái
phạm vi và.
Cái nhóm người dùng master ở đó master cơ
bản ban đầu và mình xây dựng cho cái nhóm
người dùng master đó thôi.
Sau đó là nếu mà nó có thể mở rộng và
được tái sử dụng ở các cái chức năng khác
thì càng tốt.
Nhưng mà cái phần lúc mà triển khai cái
dự án ban đầu là người ta sẽ đi đến vô
một cái chỗ phù hợp như vậy và mình trình
bày sau thôi chứ người ta sẽ hiếm khi
mình tiếp xúc một cái dự án mà triển khai
toàn diện thôi mà thường cái dự án mà chỉ
lớn như vậy.
Người ta cũng sẽ kiểu chia thành các gói
nhỏ và giao cho các nhóm để làm thôi chứ
hiếm khi một nhóm mà nó có thể làm được
nhiều,
làm nhiều như một nhóm mà có thể làm rất
là nhiều công việc và xây dựng.
Các tất cả các thành phần và đáp ứng cho
tất cả các quy trình,
đâu thường nó sẽ chia thành các gói nhỏ
ha nên đối với cái phạm vi nhóm của mình
và thời gian mà cái môn này mình đang
được triển khai học á,
thì cô gợi ý là các em chọn vài lớp thôi.
Đối với cái ngành của mình nha,
lớp nói chung là cô không giới hạn lớp ở
đây sẵn đây,
cô nói về cái phạm vi bài đồ án luôn,
cô không giới hạn lớp.
Nhưng mà khuyến nghị thì khoảng 1 2 lớp
trở lên ha,
đừng ít quá mà cũng đừng nên ôm đồm quá
nhiều, ôm đồm quá nhiều,
không hạn chế chọn cả 5 lớp nha em chọn
ít 1 2 lớp thôi.
Hoặc là 2 3 lớp,
đó là ai đấy 2 3 lớp là phải là phải như
đẹp.
Còn đối với cái và các thành phần như là
phần cứng, phần mềm, mạng,
quản trị với bỏng, quản trị bảo mật.
Thì cô cho các em đặt ngữ cảnh luôn đặt
ngữ cảnh luôn là giả sử là hạ tầng phần
cứng với lại hạ tầng mạng,
cái công ty nó ổn rồi.
Nên khi em đầu tư cái lớp năng lực số 5
chẳng hạn,
em chỉ đầu tư vào cái hệ thống phần mềm
và cái phần quản trị bảo mật thôi.
Kem hình dung là kem có quyền trong một
lớp đó và kem chọn thành phần mình đầu tư
luôn không nhất thiết là kem phải đầu tư
hết tất cả các thành phần như là trong
cái khung tham chiếu như là phần cứng,
phần mềm mạng quản trị bảo mật.
Tại vì cái này thực chất mỗi cái nó là
một nhánh riêng,
một cái nhánh riêng nên cô không nhất
thiết là mình đặt và giống như là đối với
các dự án mà cô triển khai hoặc là người
ta nói về cái hiện trạng á là sẽ có sự
hợp tác giữa các nhóm và tái sử dụng.
Và có những phần có sẵn chứ không phải
lần nào mình cũng đầu tư hết toàn bộ đâu
ha nên ở đây các em có thể thảo luận để
chọn thứ nhất là lớp thì mình chọn vài
lớp và các thành phần triển khai thì các
em sẽ giả lập.
Kịch bản gia lập là công ty nó đã thiết
kế,
thí dụ giống như đối với cái ngành của
mình,
á là các em thiên về công nghệ thông tin,
thiên về phần mềm. Và thiên về,
nếu mà bên ngành của mình có một số môn
cũng có,
các em có thể học về quản trị với bảo mật.
Một phần thì 3 cái thành phần như phần
mềm quản trị bảo mật và nó liên quan đến
chuyên ngành của các em nhiều hơn.
Thì các em có thể chọn 3 cái đó thôi,
3 cái thành phần đó thôi.
Còn cái phần cứng với mạng thì phần cứng
thì nó mang tính chất kiểu thiết bị đầu
tư và nó hơi thiên về kỹ thuật máy tính
nhiều hơn là cái ngành công nghệ thông
tin của mình.
Bên thiết kế viên mạch cho các hạ tầng
cứng.
Còn mạng làm bên khoa mạng máy tính và
truyền thông.
À chứ nó cũng không phải chuyên mình
nhiều lắm nên nếu mình chọn mà mình sẵn
tìm hiểu và liên quan tới cái ngành và
phạm vi của mình á thì thường là các em
nên chọn phần mềm quản trị với bảo mật.
Tại vì phần mềm khi mình triển khai thì
mình sẽ cũng sẽ xem xét tới phần quản trị
và cái phần bảo mật thông tin nó giống
như là một kỹ năng mà cái kỹ sư phát
triển phần mềm hoặc là kỹ sư người làm về
dữ liệu người ta phải biết về kỹ kiến
thức đó.
Nên 3 cái phần này thường thường liên
quan với nhau và nó liên quan đến chuyên
ngành của em nhiều hơn nên cô khuyến
không có, không có bắt buộc gì.
Cô chỉ khuyến nghị là cái nào gần như các
em chọn thì nó có lợi nhiều hơn thôi.
Còn sự lựa chọn vẫn là cô khác nhóm.
Phần mềm quản trị bảo mật rồi về các lớp
á.
Thì.
Hồng thì các em sẽ dính tới cái nhiều
nhất là cái ốp platform hoặc là cái lớp
là lớp số 2, hoặc là lớp số 4.
Lớp số 2, lớp số 4 và lớp số 5, lớp 2,
lớp 4,
lớp 5 là 3 cái lớp mà các em các cái chủ
đề nghiên cứu trong cái ngành của mình.
Nó liên quan nhiều nhất á mà các em có
thể lựa chọn các cái lớp nào mà gần với
cái mình để mình tìm hiểu và sau đây mình
học các cái môn thì sao?
Nó đem lại lợi ích cho mình nhiều hơn
cũng được. Đó là gợi ý của cô,
thường thì nếu mà tầng ứng dụng á thì
mình hay các em hay yêu đương làm việc
với cái lớp 2 với lớp số 4 nhiều hơn.
Lớp 2, lớp 4, còn cái lớp dữ liệu á là.
Nó có 2 là phần mềm ứng dụng,
còn lớp dữ liệu là nói chung là hồi nãy
bạn nói là dữ liệu là nó chuyên về phần
dữ liệu luôn á,
nó giống như một mảng độc lập nên thường
nếu các em sẽ học các cái môn thì các em
sẽ học một số môn nói chuyên về dữ liệu
luôn á trong thí dụ bên.
Con không biết các em học cái môn này
chưa ha tới mà vô trường thì mình sẽ
thường học các môn nền tảng liên quan với
tư duy lập trình để các em làm xây dựng
lớp 2, lớp 4 á.
Và một cái môn chuyên về dự các môn
chuyên về dữ liệu để các em biết về lớp 5
bây giờ thật sự là bây giờ tách ra nhiều
ngành nhưng mà cỡ nào nó cũng sẽ phải
đụng tới mấy cái đó học bên đây dù em có
là ngành nào.
Báo trí tuệ nhân tạo, khoa học dữ liệu,
công nghệ,
phần mềm thiết kế vi mạch hay làm ăn máy
tính truyền thông thì các em đều phải có
tư duy lập trình nên các bộ của mình sẽ
học đó và phần lớn đều sẽ phải biết xây
dựng các web app cơ bản.
Nên mình sẽ học các môn và như là nhập
môn lập trình, lập trình hướng đối tượng,
lập trình web, lập trình app.
Còn nếu mà liên quan bên viên mạch hoặc
là mạng thì bảo mật thì mình sẽ học các
cái app chuyên về.
À,
các cái thành phần về bảo mật trong cái
phần về bảo mật nhiều hơn.
Còn nếu mà bên thiết kế vi mạch á thì em
sẽ học được trình nhúng nhiều hơn.
Thì có thêm cái lập trình nhúng nhưng mà
lập trình riêng mình cũng phải học luôn
rồi ha, lập trình nhúng được kiểu phụ.
Theo chuyên ngành.
Thì học cái đó thêm thôi.
Là lập hình phần đó,
còn vào cái nhánh thứ 2 là nhánh liên
quan tới lớp 5 là phần về dữ liệu,
chắc bắt buộc mình phải học luôn vô là
phải học về cơ sở dữ liệu.
Em phải hiểu về cái cách dữ liệu là gì?
Cách mà công nghệ thông tin quản trí dữ
liệu.
Sau đó rồi bắt đầu mình mới học về,
có thể là về nhà coi dữ liệu,
về khai thác dữ liệu. Vân vân,
phát triển sau này, nâng cao lên.
Nhưng mà cơ sở dữ liệu bắt buộc mình phải
có.
Và phải có cái lớp cơ bản và cái lớp dữ
liệu hiện tại,
á nó không phải chỉ là cái lớp lưu trữ
thông tin dữ liệu theo kiểu là dùng để
quản lý,
mà nó là nền tảng để phát triển cho tất.
Cho các công nghệ mới nổi hiện nay mà em
nghe rất là nhiều về trí tuệ nhân tạo.
Thế là nhân tạo chất phát triển dựa trên
dữ liệu.
Em muốn build ra một cái bộ đồ AI thì em
phải có nguyên liệu để em build nó nên
bắt buộc phải có dữ liệu và dữ liệu ở đây
thì lúc đó nó sẽ không phải là dữ liệu
dùng để quản lý mà dữ liệu dùng để khai
thác nên em sẽ nghe tới cái khái niệm về
cái công nghệ lưu trữ dữ liệu dùng để
khai thác model.
Và xây dựng bộ đồ ai á,
như là Daterlay hay Latow gì đó,
đó là cái gọi là nhà kho dữ liệu nên cái
phần dữ liệu này về cái khảo sát của các
nhóm mà khi mà gọi là ứng muốn ứng dụng
các công nghệ mới hiện tại.
Như là ứng dụng của trí tuệ nhân tạo
giống như công ty nào người ta cũng muốn
xây dựng, khai thác tri thức từ dữ liệu,
rồi phát triển các hệ thống trí tuệ nhân
tạo.
Thì mình phải có xây dựng cái nhà kho dữ
liệu cho mình.
Để kho dữ liệu, hoặc là họ data lay thôi,
mình sử dụng đúng từ nó dịch qua tiếng
việt, nó bắt cược, nó hơi kỳ kỳ.
Là data quen sao, hoặc data lake hay law.
Bắt buộc mình phải có cái đó để mình phát
triển các công nghệ mới.
Nên cái và cái lượng phát triển dữ liệu
hiện tại khá là tốc độ khá là nhanh nên
hầu như các doanh nghiệp hiện tại hoặc là
các cái hoạt động ở trường bản thân ở
trường mình cũng vậy là.
Phải đầu tư cái lớp số 5 về dữ liệu rất
là nhiều nên nếu mà trong cái.
Đề xuất mà đầu tư của mình thường thì
người ta sẽ muốn phát triển các lớp khác
thì lớp dữ liệu nó cũng sẽ đi theo phạm
vi thay đổi ứng dụng của em,
nó có nhiều phân hệ cho nhiều nhóm người
dùng nhiều hơn.
Thì dữ liệu cũng phải lớn lên theo số
lượng người tăng lên,
em xây dựng nhiều ứng dụng nhiều hơn các
số lượng người dùng tăng lên mà cái nền
tảng dữ liệu của em không phát triển theo
thì cái hạ tầng của em nó sẽ.
Bị chậm,
bị chậm và nó sẽ không có khó có những
cung cấp dữ liệu cho mấy cái ứng dụng
phát triển chi phí thời hiện tại hiện tại
được nên thường là lớp 5 sẽ mọi người sẽ
đầu tư khá là nhiều.
Và và nó phải phát triển liên tục hơn thì
đó là một số cái gợi ý mà phù hợp về cái
xu hướng và phù hợp với cái ngành của các
em.
Còn lại thì do các nhóm trao đổi với nhau
và lựa chọn.
Còn về cái phần bài sữa của nhóm bạn Tài
thì khá là ổn rồi,
chỉ có cái là do các bạn chọn vô một ngữ
cảnh cụ thể nhưng mà được một cái là mấy
cái phần tìm hiểu thì các bạn dễ tìm hiểu
theo cái thành phần chung công nghệ chung
thiết bị chung.
Nhưng mà các bạn có đặt vô ngữ cảnh của
thầy và có một qua vài phần nói về cái
công ty cái này thì muốn là mình sẽ kiểm
tra vô sẽ kiểm tra trong vài phần đồ án
cho khi mà các em chọn doanh nghiệp.
Và dựa trên cái tài liệu mà các em cung
cấp mà cơ chế sao nên cái phần ở đây bài
ở đây sửa thì cô không có nói gì phần đó.
Tại vì cô không yêu cầu hả chủ yếu là nói
về các cái lớp.
Ở và các thành phần trong cơ sở thông tin
thông tin thôi và chú ý cho em về gợi ý
cho các em về một số lựa chọn phù hợp với
mình.
Hoặc.
Rồi cái đó là cái phần sửa bài tập ngày
hôm nay ha các em có chỗ này không rõ nữa
luôn.
Còn nếu không có chỗ nào không rõ thì bây
giờ mình sẽ tới cái khâu tiếp theo.
Cao siêu.
Dạ cô cho em hỏi là cái deadline đề tài
mình là khi nào cô?
Hôm nay có cập nhật danh sách nè.
Chạy.
Nếu mình đăng ký chưa?
Ở nhóm em đăng ký.
Ok, giờ cô cập nhật hết.
Dạ em cảm ơn dạ.
Rồi bây giờ con sẽ cập nhật danh sách đề
tài cho các nhóm luôn á,
rồi để mình học tiếp nội dung mới,
nội dung mới hôm nay cũng không có quá
khó nên cô sẽ dành một phần thời gian để
nói về cái.
Hướng dẫn thực hiện đồ án để làm cái phần
bài tập và.
Chuẩn bị cho cái bài tập về nhà của mình.
À,
nhóm 1 cái phải cho cô coi cái thêm mấy
cái thông tin này,
hiện tại cô sẽ tạm thời ru cái thông tin
đề tài công ty mà các em đăng ký.
Nhưng mà là trong cái phần bài tập tiếp
theo và các để mình làm thì các em tìm
hiểu và các em trình bày thêm về cái nội
dung này của mình nha các em để mình có
cơ sở để mình làm cái bài tập.
Bài tập này.
Xác định phạm vi đề xuất của mình.
Chứ không có cái thông tin này thì mình
không biết là tại vì mình là xây dựng cái.
Đề xuất đầu tư mình lên cái phương án mà
mình lựa chọn phương án đầu tư cho người
ta cho cái công ty đó.
Nhưng mà mình cũng cần phải biết một số
cái hiện trạng cơ bản của công ty để mình
đạt cái ngữ cảnh cho nó phù hợp á các em.
Chứ mình không có thông tin gì hết,
không biết cái công ty nó đang đầu tư ở
trong cái quy mô nào và cái kỳ vọng phát
triển về mức độ số hóa phát triển trong
tương lai nó ra sao thì mình rất là khó
đưa vô cái phần lập luận.
Về tính cấp thiết và tính mới của đề tài
luôn, em.
Các bạn nào mà thực có phần thực hiện đồ
án đồ thì các em sẽ biết về tính cấp
thiết về tính mới và tài ha.
Những 1.
Nhấn 7 đâu.
Chủ nhà hàng lẩu Hadi Law này các cơ sở
hạ tầng hiện có của nó có như thế nào các
em, các em ghi vậy không?
Cô không biết mà tại thường thường cái
bên nhà hàng á họ không có lành mạnh về
phần này và họ có một số cái.
Đầu tư cơ bản để quản lý thôi.
Nếu mà chị có đầu tư cơ bản mà mình làm
dự án phát triển lên á,
mà cái nhu cầu của họ không cần tới thì
nó sẽ hơi khó đó nha em.
Nhưng 7 luôn ta.
Tại vì đến mấy.
Dạ em.
Sao những bài sao cái này kem cho cô biết
cái quy mô cơ bản ở đây đi.
Dạ để em bổ sung thêm sau.
Tại đi mô tả đi em để cô biết là cô coi
cái đề tài nó ổn không để cô cập nhật
À
luôn.
Dạ thì.
Ý của em là muốn gọi là quản lý các cái
chi nhánh của cuộc ở phạm vi gì trong
nước Việt Nam thôi.
Đi cái hiện tại hiện tại cái cái.
Cho cô biết miêu tả sơ,
miêu tả sơ về cái phạm vi của doanh
Cái phương án.
nghiệp với lại cái nền tảng công nghệ ở
các công ty mà các em chọn nó như thế nào
đó có đủ lớn hơn và nó có nhu cầu cần để
phát triển.
Công nghệ mới không?
Chứ giống như cái chuỗi nhà hàng hoặc cái
nhà hàng đó là kiểu ờ cái phạm vi của nó
là chỉ là một cái nhà hàng kinh doanh
bình thường, còn quản lý thu chi.
Và họ chạy cái quảng cáo thì họ chạy trên
các nền tảng nguyên xã hội thôi chứ họ
không có cái quy mô công ty đủ lớn để họ
phát triển cái quản lý dữ liệu và có nhu
cầu ứng dụng các công nghệ mới để nâng
cao cái.
Dịch vụ của họ đang thí dụ ví dụ như vậy
chứ họ chị không có nhu cầu thì khi mà
các em chọn cái đề tài này nó khó phát
triển lắm á.
Dạ tại vì hiện tại em đang nghĩ là đang
phát triển là hợp lại là phần BOS rồi
À.
phần quản lý kho kế toán với lại COM là
một cái adpication xong rồi từ đó mà phát
triển lên nó tùy ý của tụi em đang hướng
tới đây.
Nhưng mà là ở đây,
các em mấy cái thông tin cơ bản này,
các em có hiểu, các em có thể tìm,
có tìm hiểu được và xác định định vị được
cái công ty mà các em đang chọn không?
Là có tài liệu để mình định vị cơ bản
theo cái yêu cầu này không giống như bối
cảnh này, các vấn đề hiện tại nè.
Dạ có nhưng mà nó chưa có đầy đủ lắm để
em thảo luận thêm với mấy bạn.
Rồi cái cô tạm thời, cô ghi,
cái mà nhưng mà phải,
cái em phải xác định được 2 cái này.
Dạ vâng.
Mình không cần biết mình không cần phải
thanh tra hoặc là biết quá kỹ về công cái
doanh nghiệp và lựa chọn mình chỉ cần
biết cái bối cảnh doanh nghiệp nó có hoạt
động trong ngành và có quy mô như thế nào
và nó có một số cái vấn đề hoặc là định
hướng phát triển, nó **** kỳ vọng nó.
Muốn đạt tới thông qua thí vụ báo cáo tài
chính hoặc là các trang web quảng bá của
công ty hoặc trên trang web giới thiệu
với công ty chẳng hạn.
Các em chỉ cần nắm được một vài thông tin
cơ bản này thôi thì khi mình đặt ngữ cảnh
đầu tư thì nó sẽ dễ.
Thấy hưng và nó hợp lý hơn.
Chứ mà nó không có cái gì hết thì giống
như xem xét lại nha.
Dạ.
Rồi cô ghi tạm thở này hả?
Tôi sẽ nói luôn, nói chứ không quên.
Chưa khảo sát cơ bản nha.
Ngân hàng hả?
Nhóm này của mình,
nhóm 3 Kang cũng chưa khảo sát hả các em?
Sao cô của lưu hướng dẫn đăng ký rồi mà
nếu mình đưa cho cô cái tên không vậy?
Những bà nào.
Dạ, thưa cô, để có gì em bổ sung nha con.
Tại vì em thấy mọi người để để có gì em
bổ sung xong gửi lại.
Ừm, nếu có hướng dẫn các em ừm.
Dạ dạ.
Nhóm 10 cũng chưa đủ thông tin nha.
Em chưa đủ thông tin yêu cầu nha,
những người 4 nhóm đăng ký sớm nhưng mà
lại không có đưa thông tin khảo sát cho
các em.
Nếu 10 có đeo không?
Nó vừa có bằng đại học không?
Rồi thằng với 10 không có thông tin.
Dạ cô em có cha trong con chết á em đang
mất tiếng nên không có tiền để nói á cô.
Nếu mức
Ừ.
Nếu mờ nhân bổ sung cho em.
Dạ vâng.
Ở nhóm này, nhóm chính cũng ổn và heo.
Những bán được tăng.
Nhưng ta biết mình phải cần làm gì cho.
Đến 8
Tính toán của bạn nào đi học không?
Là có cô
giờ.
Ừ, nhóm 8 bổ sung khảo sát nha các em.
Dạ dạ vâng con.
Ở cơ hội tức là tụi em bị là nếu mà đang
suy nghĩ là nếu mà khảo sát xong á thì ví
dụ như.
Một chi nhánh với lại một thằng tổng công
ty á thì có thể là nó hơi nhiều quá nên
là tụi em đang tính là nếu mà.
Nó nó chỉ làm tổng không rồi sau này đổi
lại được hả cô?
Tại vì như nó ít quá thì thêm vào á cô.
Cô đâu có yêu cầu em đi khảo sát,
đây đâu phải chương trình cũ đâu các em,
Dạ.
chương trình cũ là cô yêu cầu các em đi
khảo sát cái công ty đó thì mình sợ các
công ty phạm vi quá lớn,
mình khảo sát không được.
Còn này mình đang nghiên cứu đề xuất dự
án.
Đầu tư mà.
Và cái phần khảo sát thì kem chỉ cần nắm
được 2 cái thông tin cơ bản này là để
mình đặt cái ngữ cảnh,
phạm vi và cái nhu cầu cấp tính cấp để
đưa ra đến cấp thế giới tính mới của đề
tài là được.
Hay là mình lượng sức rồi mình nghiên cứu.
Nãy giờ có nghe cái sổ bài không?
Bây giờ có,
nhưng mà vì em đang thắc mắc chỗ đó nên
lúc này em có giơ tay mà cô chưa dạ.
Cái sự sự bài,
sửa bài lúc đó là cô có gợi ý cho các em
các lớp nhân cách phạm vi giới hạn các
lớp năng lực đầu tư và các thành phần
mình có thể giả lập là nó có rồi,
và mình có thể gợi ý các thành phần gần
với mình nhất.
Dạ em có nghe ạ.
Ừm đúng rồi,
thì cái vụ cái công ty đó nó lớn quá và
kem thì khi mà mình làm thì kem có thể
chọn một lớp năng lực thôi và kem có thể
giả lập là cái phần cứng và tài nguyên
mạng của công ty.
Nó đáp ứng nhu cầu rồi và mình chỉ cần.
Đầu tư thêm đề xuất đầu tư thêm phần mềm
và cái phần quản trị bảo mật thôi thì cái
công ty lớn thì cái nhu cầu quản trị bảo
mật cao thì các em có thể đề xuất các
công nghệ quản trị bảo mật mới thôi.
Phù hợp.
Chứ các em chọn một cái phạm vi nhỏ quá
thì cái nhu cầu,
Em hiểu được.
cái nhu cầu về cái quản trị bảo vật của
nó thấp thì cái phần mà em đề xuất mình
không có đặt ra cái cảnh tìm hiểu các
công nghệ mới được. Nó sẽ không có hay.
đúng không
À em hiểu rồi.
Ở đây cũng nói thêm,
ví dụ giống như là kem chọn lớp năng lực
lớp dữ liệu đi và thường thì ví dụ một số
nhóm các bạn trước đây là các bạn hay
chọn lớp dữ liệu và các em hay bạn đều
đặt ra một ngữ cảnh và phần cái vấn đề
này thường thường là công ty nào nó cũng
hay bị hiện tại á.
Không phải công ty nào cũng có hết.
Nhưng mà thường thì gặp phải gặp phải là
chưa đồng bộ hóa dữ liệu ở giữa các cái
chi nhánh.
Và nó gây trở ngại cho cái quy trình bán
hàng có thể là thí dụ khách hàng.
Người ta đặt một cái sản phẩm thì sản
phẩm kia nó cũng có,
nhưng mà cái chi nhánh khác có.
Nhưng mà do các chi nhánh không đồng bộ
dữ liệu với nhau thì cái.
Các nhân viên s tìm hiểu,
tìm kiếm á nó sẽ khó và cái và sẽ có
những trường hợp nó chưa đồng bộ kịp,
có nghĩa là trên trang web là báo còn
hàng nhưng mà khi khách hàng tới chi
nhánh nước mua thì nó lại hết hàng.
Mà khi mà mình chưa đồng bộ về dữ liệu
thì nó sẽ dẫn đến các vấn đề khó khăn
trong quy trình làm việc cơ bản.
Và cái thứ hai là mình,
cái dữ liệu mình nó không thống nhất.
Thì nó có tổng mức à.
Nó có đồng bộ trên cái data life của mình
để hỗ trợ cho cái cung cấp dữ liệu để
mình ứng dụng khai thác,
để mình xây dựng các cái hệ thống trí tuệ
nhân tạo chẳng hạn.
Cái đó là ví dụ, đó là cái vấn đề các bạn,
cái ngữ cảnh các bạn đặt ra và đề xuất
đầu tư ở đây cô.
Các bạn là muốn xây dựng một cái lớp dữ
liệu hoàn chỉnh để đáp ứng cái nhu cầu sử
dụng đồng bộ hóa và nó hoàn thiện.
Các cái quy trình nghiệp vụ của công ty,
tất cả các chi nhánh và có thể tổng hợp
dữ liệu thành một cái day life of life
house hoặc là leader warehouse lớn để hỗ
trợ mình khai thác dữ liệu và xây dựng
cái ứng dụng PI thông minh tốt hơn chẳng
hạn.
Cái ngữ cảnh có đó là một ví dụ ngữ cảnh
của cô đặt ra cho cái em dễ hình dung á
nên cái phạm vi ở đây nó.
Là nó chỉ là cái phạm vi để nó sẽ có thể
đưa ra cái ngữ cảnh ờ xây dựng ra cái xác
định ra được các cái vấn đề còn tồn tại
để các em dễ đặt ra cái mô tả cái ngữ
cảnh ứng dụng chung các các cái.
Tài năng còn tồn tại và từ đó để mình đưa
ra cái là cơ sở lý do để mình đầu tư cho
lớp năng lực này và nó có đem lại được
cái lợi ích gì thì nếu mà miêu tả được
theo phong cách đó thì nó đang thể hiện
tính cách thiết của đề tài.
Và nếu mình có áp dụng công nghệ mới để
có giải quyết được cái vấn đề trên và các
cái hệ thống hiện tại của công ty nó chưa
đáp ứng được thì mình có thể nó là cái
phần tính mới, diễn giải nó là tính mới.
Rồi đó là nhóm 8 tiếp theo là nhóm 6.
Cái đề tài này cũng ổn, cái chỗ mà này nè,
các em nên đứng ở góc nhìn cao hơn,
cái em giống như hồi nãy.
Cô có ví dụ 2 nhóm 6.
Là cái dữ liệu của mình đồng bộ không
phải chỉ là cái việc về cái địa chỉ ở đây
Dạ.
mà nó có thể liên quan tới cái việc đồng
bộ dữ liệu về quản lý chung cho nhiều quy
trình vận hành ở cái công ty.
Nghiệp đó,
ngoài ra là khi dữ liệu nó đã được đồng
bộ rồi thì cái việc mà quản trị dữ liệu
để khai thác nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn.
Cái khâu tiền xử lý dữ liệu hoặc là nó
tránh việc nó xảy giống như là cái hồ dữ
liệu mà thông tin có rất nhiều nhưng mà
không biết khai thác và dùng từ đâu á?
Thì cái việc mình đầu tư cái lớp năng lực
dữ liệu này mà nó ổn á thì nó sẽ giải
quyết được các cái vấn đề dữ liệu trong
quản lý và dữ liệu trong khai thác ứng
dụng PI của cơ bản hoặc là giữ.
Liệu cho ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo mới
hiện tại.
Nếu mà các em nhìn ở góc độ lớn hơn thì
lúc mà mình biết cái thuyết minh, đề xuất,
đề tài á nó mới hay được khi em.
Là cái rất là gợi ý của con.
Nhà hàng nhân.
Dạ cô ơi,
cho em hỏi là cái lớp năng lực đầu tư dự
kiến nó nếu như mà.
Thì hôm nay chốt rồi là không thay đổi
được luôn đúng không cô?
Hay là nếu chỉ giữa chừng?
Không,
trong cái quá trình mình học và cô cho
các em làm các bài tập liên quan với các
em tìm hiểu để mà đánh giá xem cái đề tài
này nó có thể triển khai được hay không.
Cái hàng thứ 2 là nó có hợp lý hay không
và nó có nằm trong khả năng làm cô nhóm
hay không?
Ừm và tới cái à và nửa cái bài tập trên
lớp,
mặc dù nó liên quan tới đầu án nhưng mà
nó chỉ là cái phần để cho các em làm quen
và hỗ trợ ban đầu thôi chứ nó không phải
là cái sản phẩm cuối cùng như các em.
Sau đó thì khi mà các em làm xong cái đó
thì cái cô mình mới tổng hợp lại thành
một cái báo cáo.
Và chính thức thí dụ một cái báo cáo cho
đầu tư các lớp năng lực lớn trong đội án
môn học và đầu tư cho một cái phần phát
triển một cái phần mềm cho các doanh
nghiệp của mình đang có bài thực hành.
Lúc đó các em mới hoàn thiện ở trên đây
và các em có thể hiệu chỉnh.
Cái sự lựa chọn của mình chỉ là trước cái
ngày mà chốt cái này thì thường thì cô sẽ
có một cái buổi hướng dẫn sữa.
Thì khi lúc đó là cô sẽ nói các thông tin
và tư vấn cho các em thì các em cố gắng
là tới đó là mình chốt luôn và mình không
thay đổi nữa.
Tại vì nếu mà các em thay đổi thì cái tới
lúc mà thi chính thức vấn đáp chính thức
á.
Thầy cô sẽ cần biết lý do vì sao kem có
sự thay đổi đó.
Có thể trước đây có cái nhóm đầu em chọn
chị,
nhưng mà sau đó cái mạng không nổi nên
cái em bỏ thì có thường thường mình sẽ có
những cái lý do đó và cô sẽ phải kiểm tra
và xem xét lại cái sự lựa chọn mới của
mình.
Mà nếu mà cái sự lựa chọn đó của em nó
sai thì mình chịu luôn nha cái em.
Còn tại vì nó đã qua cái thời gian tư vấn
đề tài đồ án khoa học của cô rồi.
Nếu lúc đầu các em chọn có vấn đề gì thì
cô sẽ góp ý luôn,
còn qua cái hạn góp ý rồi bắt đầu tới
giai đoạn các em tự hoàn thiện,
các em đọc bài mà lúc đó các em có sự
thay đổi nữa thì các em cô không có góp ý
nữa thì đúng lúc đó các em làm có vấn đề
sai gì thì.
À,
nó lại tiết cho mình thế nên thường của
Huy ghét nhóm là cố gắng trước cái ngày
mà cô báo,
thường thường cái ngày đó cô sẽ thông tin
ở trên đây.
Cô thông báo trên đây cái ngày thi vấn
đáp á thì.
Và nghề nghệ sữa,
sữa lần cuối trước khi thị phương đáp thì
mình cố gắng đăng ký và chốt các cái nội
dung mình làm ở cái ngày đó.
Còn ở đây thì cô chỉ ghi ghi để lưu thông
tin thôi.
Dạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Dạ a lô ạ.
Dạ em xin đại diện nhóm 11,
em cập nhật luôn cái doanh nghiệp,
tụi em đăng ký luôn được không cô?
Thì các em cập nhật lên cái trong cái bài
post này.
Dạ rồi.
À,
em thấy các nhóm mà các bạn cập nhật đầy
đủ giống như ví dụ giống sáo,
dính chín nè, hoặc là nhím sáo nè,
kem làm tương tự với các bạn.
Dạ dạ dạ, dạ rồi em cảm ơn cô.
Nhưng mà các em chỉ cập nhật mô tả thôi,
cái đề tài mình không thay đổi đúng không?
Công ty lựa chọn của mình nó thay đổi
đúng không?
Dạ.
Các em chỉ cập nhật bối cảnh doanh nghiệp
vấn đề thôi, đúng không?
Và tạm em.
Cái đề tài công ty thì mình.
Dạ, mấy cái đó thì em có,
tại tụi em vẫn chưa có xác định rõ được
các lớp để phát triển được.
Thế ý câu hỏi là kem chỉ cập nhật mấy cái
thông bối cảnh và vấn đề thôi,
còn các công ty các em không thay đổi
đúng không?
Dạ đúng rồi, dạ đúng rồi.
Ừ,
nếu mà công ty có kem có thay đổi kem
khai báo để cô cập nhật lại trên cái ship
này nha tên công ty là chính xác.
Dạ dạ dạ.
cảm ơn.
Rồi mình có thể tắt giơ tay.
Cho em hỏi là nếu mà nếu mà mình đổi đề
tài thì thời gian tối đa.
Cúi để mình đổi là ngày mấy con.
Nó tùy theo cái lịch học buổi của em,
tại vì nếu mà cô không có việc bận thì
mình học liên tục thì thường nó sẽ là
buổi thứ 7, học buổi thứ 8.
Cái buổi đó là mình chốt đề tài luôn chứ
mình không có thay đổi rồi đúng không cô?
Cô phí nghĩa là không nên thay đổi,
nếu mà có trường hợp thay đổi thì cô sẽ
Dạ dạ, em cảm ơn.
xem xét riêng ở,
còn cái ngày mà nào mà là ngày bù số 7
tháng 8,
ngày mà sửa cái bài tập thực hành.
Nghĩa là đồ án của mình á thì cái khi mà
tới cái ngày đó thì cô sẽ công bố thông
báo cho đi leanin và báo trước đây một
tuần để các em chuẩn bị.
Ở bên này cũng được.
Ở hai của nhóm mà hai cũng ổn rồi.
Công ty cổ phần.
Bây giờ hiện tại là nhóm 10,
nhóm 4 với nhóm 11 mình chưa đăng ký hả
em?
Nãy nhớ 11 là báo,
con là các em sẽ đăng ký đúng không?
Rồi cô đợi các em bổ sung còn nhóm 4 đâu.
Nhà dạ
Nhưng muốn có bạn nào đi học không sao,
em 2 tuần rồi mà mình chưa đăng ký với em.
Dạ để tụi em cập nhật sâu được không cô?
Rồi.
Nếu mà kem cập nhật sao.
Để đi trong tối nay tụi em cập nhật.
Cố gắng trong gói này,
em cập nhật để mình có phần làm bài tập
Dạ dạ.
nha các em và đọc kỹ hướng dẫn trên cái
bài post cung cấp đủ thông tin cho các em
nạp trẻ thì nên đầy đủ này nha.
Chờ dạ.
Rồi.
Cô đã cập nhật cái danh sách này tài trên
cái ship, các em có thể vô kiểm tra lại.
Nhóm nào mà sai thì báo cô nha các em.
Bây giờ là mình học tiếp về cái nội dung
chương 3, chương 3 thì nó dễ thôi.
Chương 3 là nói về phần mềm của nó là
phần cứng.
Coi chương 3 đúng rồi,
phần cứng và lưu trữ các khái niệm về
phần cứng và lưu trữ thôi. Sau đó là.
Sau đó là mình sẽ coi cái phần mà hướng
dẫn thực hành ở cái bước số 0 xác định
phạm vi đề tài.
Rồi có thể giao bài tập và cho kem làm.
Nói về cái.
Nội dung chương 3 này của mình ha là mình
sẽ tìm hiểu kỹ hơn về các khái niệm về
phần cứng.
Và ok em vẫn còn thấy cái màn hình vô
đúng không à?
Thấy không ta.
Là cái mà sẽ tìm hiểu kỹ hơn cái khái
niệm về phần cứng và lưu trữ trong hạ
tầng công nghệ thông tin. Ở đây,
cái trong phần sửa của nhóm 6 bạn từ hồi
nãy là các bạn cũng có giới thiệu sơ cho
các em khái niệm về các thành phần,
phần cứng.
Đúng rồi và ở đây mình cũng tiếp xúc khá
là nhiều rồi nên ở đây cô các khái niệm
nào quen rồi,
cô sẽ nói nhanh hơn rồi mình vô cái phần
hướng dẫn thực hành.
Thì đối với các thành phần phần cứng ở
đây,
mình sẽ tìm hiểu về vai trò của các phần
cứng và mình sẽ làm quen về một số các
cái thiết bị phần cứng thường sẽ được đầu
tư.
Trao cơ sở là người thông tin ở doanh
nghiệp.
Đầu tiên thì vai trò của phần cứng thì nó
là tập hợp các thiết bị vật lý,
tạo nên nền tảng vận hành cho hệ thống
công nghệ thông tin.
Ở đây các em có hình thể hình dung á.
Mà.
Đó là mấy cái thiết bị mình cần phải khi
mà mình muốn đưa vô vận hành thì đầu tiên
mình phải có thiết bị vận hành phần cứng
các cái phần mềm nghe em nghe nói như
phần mềm này hay là tài nguyên mạng này
quản trị bảo mật.
Nó có thể vận hành được thì bắt buộc nó
phải có thiết bị phần cứng trước,
chắc chắn nó phải trả cho thiết bị phần
cứng nên cái phần này nó là cái giống như
là cái nền tảng cái móng của cái nhà mà
nắp móng khi các em xây dựng nhà gì đó.
Thì khi mà các em đầu tư hạ tầng công
nghệ thông tin em đề xuất đầu tư phát
triển, hạ tầng thông tin cho doanh nghiệp,
á thì cái thành phần đầu tiên em phải suy
nghĩ tới đó chính là cái phần cứng.
Tại vì nó sẽ hỗ trợ em xử lý cho các lớp
khác như là xử lý dữ liệu nè,
lưu trữ thông tin nè.
Hỗ trợ kết nối người dùng,
cung cấp dịch vụ và duy trì hoạt động
liên tục và tổ chức.
Ví dụ giống như ở khoa đang muốn phát
triển phòng thực nghiệm cho về trí tuệ
nhân tạo cho khoa, chẳng hạn.
Thì cái việc đầu tiên viết khi viết một
cái đề xuất cái đề xuất này sẽ viết rất
là lâu nha cái thường cái ở đây cho cho
các em làm quen thôi khi mà trong cái
phân đồ án môn học.
Còn khi đi làm á thì sẽ tùy theo.
Cái vị trí công việc của mình thì có thể
là các em sẽ có khả năng tiếp xúc cái ý
dự án đầu tư kiểu này,
đầu tư giống như đồ án khoa học.
Nhưng mà nếu mà không có tiếp xúc nhiều á
thì tối thiểu các em cũng sẽ.
Tiếp xúc với cái đề xuất đầu tư phần mềm
ở là cái phần bài tập thực hành của trang
cho các em làm ấy,
nhớ nhắc lại hai đồ án Á là đầu tư hạ
tầng lớn,
nhiều lớp có thể là nhiều lớp năng lực và
nhiều thành phần.
Và cái chi phí đầu tư của nó là bên cạnh
các cái chi phí phát triển các cái giải
pháp công nghệ thì nó sẽ có đi đôi với
việc mua thiết bị thường là cái dự án lớn
sẽ đi đôi cái phần đó. Còn cái bên.
Rồi tắc mứt của những bạn nào bạn bảo.
Còn đối với cái.
Phần mềm đầu tư và thực hành của mình là
các em đề xuất xây dựng hệ thống công
nghệ phát triển công nghệ thường là phần
mềm hoặc là bên bảo mật thì nó sẽ chi phí
nó sẽ rẻ hơn và.
Cô nghĩ huynh,
nếu mình làm đúng ngành công nghệ thông
tin thì ít nhiều các em sẽ tiếp xúc các
dự án dạng dự án xin kinh phí cho đề tài
phần mềm kiểu vậy.
Còn đối với đầu phần cứng thì tùy theo ha,
nếu mà em đi vô cái dự án mà thường là
cái dự án gọi là mở rộng hoặc là đầu tư
phát triển ngay từ ban đầu luôn giống như
từ dự án phát triển phòng lab cho khoa
hiện tại khoa chưa có lab đúng không?
Tại bây giờ khoa muốn xây dựng phòng.
Em lab thực hiện cho có thí nghiệm cho
khoa thì mình sẽ bắt đầu phải viết một
cái đề xuất.
Và giống như cái bài đồ án môn học của
mình thì đề xuất xin đầu tư thì mấy cái
bên cái trong cái 5 khung tham chiếu á
mình thì bạn trình bày hồi nãy á.
Thì cái thành phần đầu tiên mình bắt buộc
mình sẽ phải xây dựng đó chính là phần
cứng.
Nên đầu tiên là sẽ đi khảo sát coi bây
giờ phải cần mua thiết bị gì,
và thường thì trong một cái dự toán kinh
phí đầu tư thì cái thành phần này là phần
nặng tiền nhất.
Thiết bị vật lý nặng thì nên thường là
mình sẽ phải lên cái kế hoạch đầy đủ.
Ví dụ giống như các lớp năng lực hoặc là
mình sẽ coi cái hạ tầng vật lý,
phần cứng của mình.
Nó đã có những cái gì rồi,
cái nào có thể tái sử dụng và bây giờ
mình mua thêm thôi và mình định xây dựng
cái cho cái các cái lớp nào nó đã có sẵn
rồi và lớp nào còn thiếu thì mình đầu tư
thêm một số thiết bị.
Cũng cho cái phục vụ cho cái lớp mới đó
thôi,
chẳng hạn chứ không phải cái nào lúc nào
mình cũng mua mới, nhưng mà ở đây là mình,
nó là cái nền tảng bắt buộc là phần đầu
và thiết kế ban đầu luôn và bên cạnh chi
phí.
À
Đầu tư thì mình sẽ phải tính toán cái chi
phí vận hành.
Khi mình đưa xây dựng cái thuyết minh á
để người ta ước lượng kinh phí phải bỏ ra
nha cái em thì cái đó là mình cần phải
chú ý và thường thì cái vai trò khi mình
đầu tư cái thiết bị phần cứng thì nó sẽ
là nơi triển khai hệ điều hành.
Các phần mềm ứng dụng nè,
có sử dụng hay là nền tảng cho mạng nội
bộ internet dịch số hệ thống thông tin
doanh nghiệp và các thiết bị phần cứng nó
phải đủ mạnh.
Đáp ứng đủ nhu cầu tại vì nếu nó yếu thì
tất cả các thành phần phía sau dù của em
có áp dụng công nghệ mới cỡ nào nó cũng
không thể nào nhanh được.
Các em hình dung công nghệ của mình mình
nghe nói công mình muốn xây dựng một công
nghệ càng hoành tráng thì đi đôi với nó
các thiết bị.
Phần cứng nó cũng phải mạnh theo.
Ví dụ,
giống như trường của mình hay đầu tư có
mấy nay đang đầu tư các siêu máy tính.
Ví dụ,
giờ mình muốn nghiên cứu các cái mô đội
AI mới thì mình phải đầu tư các siêu máy
tính nó đủ mạnh để nó chạy các em.
Nếu mà các em muốn xây dựng mua đồ xịn
thì thường nó sẽ phải học trên lượng dữ
liệu rất lớn thì máy mình phải thật xịn
nó mới chạy được.
Chứ bây giờ máy mình yếu thì em không thể
nào xây dựng được cái công nghệ mà hiện
đại trên nó được.
Nên cái phim mà mình mua cái này,
nhưng mà nếu mà mua quá hiện đại thì kinh
phí nó rất là cao.
Nên cái khi mà mình đề xuất.
Cái.
Đầu tư cái thiết bị phần cứng á.
Thì mình phải coi cái nhu cầu tới đâu có
bao nhiêu.
Nhóm người dùng định áp dụng cho các công
nghệ gì, xây dựng các lớp năng lực gì?
Có bao nhiêu nhóm người dùng rồi nếu mà
trong thường thiết bị của mình phải dự
toán là nó phải vận hành được trong
khoảng 5 năm chẳng hạn chu kỳ 5 năm.
Thì trong vòng 5 năm,
cái dự kiến cái nhu cầu nó sẽ tăng như
thế nào gọi là mái của thiết bị mình mua
đầu tư hiện tại nó có thể đáp ứng được
chứ nó không có kiểu là kem đầu tư 1 năm
sao 1 năm sử dụng.
Cái nó không đủ và cái phải bổ sung nha.
Thì cái đó nó không hay thường người ta
nói là chu kỳ nó cũng phát triển đáp ứng
nhu cầu sử dụng trong một thời gian lâu
dài,
nhưng mà với tốc độ hiện tại và cái
thường cái chu kỳ mà cô thấy.
Mọi mọi thứ 2 thay đổi và cập nhật á thì
thường người ta chỉ cần trong khoảng chu
kỳ 5 năm cố gắng phát triển ổn được trong
chu kỳ trong năm là được.
Rồi cái khi đó mình.
Nó là nó không có quá khó với mình,
giống như mình lựa,
nhưng mà mình phải lên kế hoạch rõ ràng
để mình đưa ra cái kế hoạch mua ha,
kế hoạch mua và nó ảnh hưởng tất cả cái
tất cả các thành lớp năng lực khác ha,
và hạ tầng phần cứng tốt thì nó sẽ không
chỉ giúp hệ thống chạy.
Mẹ được mà còn giúp hệ thống chạy ổn định,
an toàn và có thể mở rộng. Giống như nãy,
cô nói ha an toàn và có thể mở rộng.
Mà trong và hỗ trợ mở rộng trong khoảng 5
năm thường là chu kỳ 5 năm.
À,
đó là cái phần cứng và tới đây kem có chỗ
nào không rõ không?
Nếu không có chỗ nào hoặc không rõ thì
mình đi tiếp ha cái này cũng quen thuộc
với mình,
đầu tiên là vì cái thiết bị phần cứng mà
thường đầu tư là cái gì.
Đầu tiên mình sẽ phải đầu tư máy chủ ha.
Thì máy chủ của mình là một cái hệ thống
máy tính có cấu hình và độ hình cao,
được thiết kế.
Nơi cung cấp dịch vụ tài nguyên hoặc dữ
liệu cho các máy khác trong mạng thì đặc
điểm cơ bản của nó là sẽ hoạt động liên
tục trong thời gian dài,
hỗ trợ cho nhiều người dùng hoặc nhiều
tiến trình,
đồng thời có khả năng mở rộng CPU ra mẫu
địa và các mạng và chú trọng.
Độ tin cậy,
khả năng dự phòng và quản trị từ xa thì à.
Cái máy chủ này nếu mà mình có kinh phí
thì mình tự mua hoặc là.
Ở đây cô thấy có một vài nhóm chọn ngân
hàng á,
ngân hàng cũng sẽ tự quản lý cái này nha
các em.
Ngân hàng có nghĩa là đối với những dữ
liệu mà.
Có độ nhạy cảm, độ bảo mật,
đòi hỏi độ bảo mật cao.
Thì bắt buộc mình phải tự mua và quản lý.
Giống như ở đây là các ngân hàng hoặc là
giống như là các dự án cấp quốc gia mà.
Cái dữ liệu đang lưu không phải những cái
các quốc gia nào cũng yêu cầu như vậy hết
tùy theo nó.
Nói chung là tùy theo nhu cầu thôi.
Nếu cái dữ liệu đó là dữ liệu thông tin
nhạy cảm và mình có khả năng tự đầu tư
quản lý được.
Và mình không thể nào giao cho bên thứ 3
thì thường cái chỗ này mình bắt buộc mình
phải tự mua tự mua và cái thường mình mua
xong rồi nó sẽ được mấy chủ của mình.
Nó sẽ có ở đây thường thường đối với các
quy mô lớn.
Thì nó sẽ có máy chủ theo các chức năng
sử dụng,
máy chủ chiên dùng để backup chuyên để
lưu trữ dữ liệu ra chứ không,
nếu mà cái công ty phần quy lớn thì
thường là một máy chủ nó sẽ không có phải
làm hết nhiều chuyện đâu, nó sẽ.
Nó sẽ được phân hóa chức năng hơn và nhu
cầu sử dụng tăng lên thì mình có thể mở
rộng cái hệ thống máy chủ đề của mình thì
máy chủ thường là một hệ thống có thể là
được thiết kế liên kết với nhau và hỗ trợ
chia sẻ dữ.
Với nhau và khi mà cái nhiệm vụ nhu cầu
tăng lên thì người ta sẽ bổ sung các cái
dễ dàng bổ sung thêm các cái máy chủ vô
cho hệ thống máy chủ hiện tại.
Và.
Ở đây,
nếu mà bạn đã tiếp xúc rồi thì mình các
em sẽ biết mấy chủ nó là các cái thiết bị
mà hiện tại phần lớn mọi người dùng đều
đang tương tác tới,
nhưng mà mình người ta không có nhìn thấy
được.
Thí dụ các cái xu hướng hiện tại là các
cái ứng dụng của mình không còn làm gì
trên các.
Máy local nữa mà các cái chức năng hoặc
là cái ta gọi là gì ta dùng từ gì để cho
các em dễ hình dung nè.
Các nghiệp vụ phức tạp,
đòi hỏi nhu cầu và xử lý cao,
đòi hỏi cái phạm vi lưu trữ lớn thì hiện
tại người ta hay chuyển qua máy chủ và để
cho máy chủ làm.
Cái này chứ người ta không có sử dụng
trên cái máy tính cá nhân nữa và cái dịch
vụ mà các em thì dùng nhiều nhất.
Nếu như lưu trú trên vai của nhóm mình
hiện tại.
Hay là.
Các cái người ta nghiên cứu,
cái ứng dụng nghiên cứu khai thác,
phân tích dữ liệu, khai thác dữ liệu,
quy mô đồ của trại hiện tại thì phần đó
các nhóm cũng hay mua trên cloud để chạy.
Thí dụ, nếu đó là một dự án ở cấp.
Cấp và có cái độ bảo mật cao á ở các
phòng thí nghiệm thì thường các phòng thí
nghiệm sẽ có hệ thống máy chủ riêng và sẽ
cho cái nhân viên hoặc là các thành viên
trong phòng lab có thể truy cập về thống
máy chủ.
Mà sử dụng máy chủ của phòng lab để chạy.
Giống như sử dụng máy chủ của trụ để chạy
cho các thành viên riêng hoặc là đặc biệt
của trường chẳng hạn.
Còn nếu mà nó dữ liệu nó không mang tính
chất nhạy cảm mà chủ yếu là giống như
tiến hành thực điểm giống như các nhóm,
các bạn giảng viên đang làm.
Là nghiên cứu cũng kiểu thực nghiệm thôi,
nghiên cứu công nghệ và nghiên cứu nghiên
cứu dạng nghiên cứu khoa học cơ bản á,
dữ liệu kiểu mang tính chất thực nghiệm
thì có thể xuống chung được mọi người hay
thuê cloud để chạy.
Tại vì cái vụ mình trạng bị một cái model
nó có thể tốn khoảng 20 giờ chẳng hạn thì
mình không thể nào chạy trên máy của mình
được mà mình sẽ luôn lưu trên cái máy chủ
và thông nhờ máy chủ thực thi cho mình.
Và mình thông qua cái phần phần mình sẽ
thông qua cái hệ thống phần mềm điều
khiển từ xa để mình chạy thì các cái
nhiệm vụ của các máy chủ hiện tại là mình
dùng nhiều lắm á.
Hầu như các cái ứng dụng công nghệ mới
xuống hiện tại là người ta đang chuyển
giao tất cả các tác vụ cần thiết để.
Cho mấy chủ làm hoặc là các ứng dụng AI
hiện tại bên trên Chest CPT hoặc cloud á,
nó hỗ trợ lập trình và chợ tự nguyện á
thì cũng là chạy trên hệ thống máy chủ
của bên nhà cung cấp đó thôi ha.
Ừ thì ở đây,
em có thể hiểu mấy chủ là ở chỗ nào cũng
cần công ty nào cũng cần đầu tư.
Nhưng bây giờ đầu tư như thế nào?
Đầu tư theo kiểu là mua về mình tự quản
lý luôn.
Hay là sử dụng thông qua dịch vụ thì tùy
theo nhu cầu và tùy theo tính chất của
cái dữ liệu và cái nghĩa vụ mình đang làm.
Hồi hồi nãy,
cô cũng nói sơ qua rồi hả anh?
Cái xà lách này nói lại kêu thôi như là
về chức năng,
chính của nó thường dùng để lưu trữ và
chia sẻ dữ liệu nè, giống như các right á.
Rồi chạy ứng dụng chung cho tổ chức.
Giống như mình đang sử dụng thảo nguyên
lên đi hiện tại của mình để mình làm hoặc
là mình dùng tin mình học nè,
cũng là mấy chủ bên Microsoft cung cấp
cho mình sử dụng thôi,
rồi dùng để quản lý tài khoản phân quyền
sách.
Thực lưu trữ và xử lý cơ sở dữ liệu,
lưu trữ,
xử lý cơ sở dữ liệu rồi sao luôn khôi
phục hoặc nhóm sang hệ thống và vai trò
của nó chính là trung tâm xử lý chung.
Tập trung tất cả các tài nguyên để giữ
quản lý thì một số cái ví dụ thực tế ha,
ví dụ như sử dụng server để quản lý cổng
thông tin sinh viên nè, các hệ thống mail,
email,
email nội bộ hoặc là các phần kế toán
phần tấn công ở trên mạng.
Chẳng hạn thì mấy chủ thường thường là nó
nơi dùng để làm vậy ha.
Về phân loại máy chủ thì nó cũng có nhiều
cái hình thức phân loại ha thì hình thức
theo phân loại vật lý là theo cái cấu
trúc của cái máy chủ ra sao thì mình nó
có nhiều dạng hoặc là theo cái chức năng
hồi nãy.
Cho cô nói là thường thường mấy chủ hiện
tại ở đây người ta theo chức năng rồi,
hoặc là theo cái mô hình triển khai và
các em muốn đặt tại doanh nghiệp đặt tại
trung tâm dữ liệu thuê ngoài hay là các
cái tài nguyên máy chủ được ảo hóa và
cung cấp qua internet.
Tùy theo cái nhu cầu của mình,
mình triển khai thôi nha.
Ví dụ giả sử em nói em muốn xây dựng cái
database server.
Tabay suver thể hiện và cái sử dụng ở đây
chừng nào nếu em đặt tại doanh nghiệp á
thì mình bắt đầu mình mới có thể kem sẽ
miêu tả thêm nếu mình em đặt tại doanh
nghiệp thì em phải mua thiết bị,
thì em mua thiết bị dạng nào thì em nên
lựa tìm hiểu về.
Cái lọ thiết bị và cái hình thức quản lý
của nó là gì để mình đưa lên cái mô hình
thiết kế và cái đó nó sẽ cực hơn và đòi
hỏi chuyên môn và đội họ có đội ngũ để xử
lý. Còn nếu mà.
Theo các mô hình triển khai khác như là
dữ liệu thuê ngoài hoặc là máy chủ của
ông hóa cung cấp internet thì các em sẽ
phải tìm hiểu về các cái dịch vụ và các
cái nền tảng cloud committing hỗ trợ hiện
tại để có sự lựa chọn phù hợp.
Trong cái hồ sơ thuyết minh của mình
giống như mình đưa đầu tư mình cái em
muốn báo giá thì các em phải xác định một
cách cụ thể, ha.
Rồi ở đây là một số cấu hình và tiêu chí
lựa chọn ha.
Thì ở đây cô có gợi ý một số cấu hình
thường quan tâm giống như là CPU nè,
có ram như thế nào?
Ổ cứng là ít SC hay là HD.
Rồi có nguồn điện dự phòng có nhiều cổng
mạng rồi,
có hỗ trợ quản trị từ xa hay không.
Rồi các em có số lượng người dùng ứng
dụng của em đang muốn chạy là cái gì ha
cái nhu cầu hiệu năng ra sao, rồi có.
Có **** muốn là dung lượng dữ liệu lưu
trữ ra sao,
có mức độ sẵn sàng cao hay không là không
được trễ ha,
còn **** muốn khả năng mở rộng như thế
nào, có thể là nếu mà muốn mở rộng.
Từ 1.000 người dùng lên 10.
000 người dùng thì chẳng hạn.
Rồi em coi ngân sách đầu tư,
cái ngân hàng ngân sách đầu tư này,
trong Minh đồ án khoa học là cho mình lựa
chọn nha các em.
Ở đây là mình đang tập nên cô sẽ không có
khoái cái em vô một loại đề tài nào cả.
Thí dụ nếu mà như mà nếu mình làm ở ngoài
thì các em phải hình dung là các em sẽ bị
giới hạn kinh phí nha các em.
Hầu hầu như tất cả các đề hầu như 100%
các đề tài cô đang tiếp xuất hiện tại
đang làm thì khi mà đăng ký đề tài cho
xin kinh phí thì nó đều có loại đề tài.
Bạn mà có ngân sách cố định hết chứ không
có cái đề tài nào mà cho mình.
Ngân sách vô tư là đại mình báo giá xong
rồi em muốn người ta chỉ đưa nhu cầu và
người ta nói ngân sách vô tư.
Em muốn làm sao cũng được rồi,
mình báo giá sao thì hiện tại là chưa
thấy cái lợi đề tài kiểu đó.
Phần lớn thì mình sẽ bị giới hạn ngân
sách.
Nên các em cân đối tất cả các tiêu chí để
mình đưa ra thì có một số cái dự án nó sẽ
đưa ra một cái giải pháp cụ thể.
Còn nếu mà bên.
Bên khách hàng,
người ta có đưa ra lựa chọn.
Người ta đưa yêu cầu cụ thể rồi thì mình
đưa ra giải pháp theo cầu của người ta
thôi.
Còn hoặc là nó là cái hướng nghiên cứu
đặt hàng thì mình đi theo đúng theo cái
hướng đó thôi.
Ở còn nếu mà là người ta chưa có mô tả rõ
ràng và hoặc là người ta yêu cầu mình cần
phải so sánh chứng minh gì thêm á thì
thường thì mình sẽ đưa ra hai ba giải
pháp và mình sẽ so đánh giá miêu tả.
Cả các thành phần trong các giải pháp đó,
rồi các đặc điểm rồi các ưu khuyết điểm
và chi phí đầu tư những lợi ích đem lại
sau đó rồi.
Mình đưa ra kết luận là gợi ý trong theo
bạn so sánh này thì cái giải pháp nào phù
hợp nhất nhưng mà mình vẫn trao quyền lựa
chọn cho bên khách hàng?
Sau khi mà mình giới thiệu rồi thì nếu mà
họ không đồng thích cái giải pháp mình
đưa ra, họ muốn xin giải pháp khác,
thí dụ mình đưa ra giải pháp mà nó mình
giải phù hợp nhất là giải pháp số 3 nhưng
người ta không thích,
người ta lựa lại giải pháp số 1 thì mình
theo thôi.
Thì cái này tùy theo cái ngữ cảnh mà khi
em đặt ra khi em muốn viết loại nào thì
các em miêu tả đặt ngược cảnh ban đầu rồi
mình viết theo cái đó.
Rồi tiếp theo là về cái máy trạm,
máy trạm này thì.
Nó có cái phạm vi nhỏ hơn so với server
và nó sẽ là phục vụ trực tiếp cho người
dùng trong quá trình làm việc, học tập,
thiết kế, vận hành và xử lý nghiệp vụ.
Và thường nó sẽ có chủ yếu phục vụ cái
tác vụ văn phòng học tập ở.
Nếu mà em vô cái vị trí công việc thì
người ta sẽ đầu tư các hệ thống máy trạm
phù hợp với nhu cầu sử dụng cho mình tùy
theo em thuộc nhóm người dùng nào thì
mình sẽ được.
Đầu tư các cái máy trạm phù hợp thì các
em có thể máy trạm ở đây là ý nghĩa theo
kiểu mô hình lan server nha các em chứ nó
không phải là loại máy trạm mà mua ngoài
thị trường nha.
Tại ở ngoài thị trường thì người ta còn
là máy tính.
Chân vào máy trạm.
Cái trạm đường có cấu hình cao và chi phí
mắc hơn mấy cá tính, cá nhân bình thường.
Còn cái máy trạm ở đây cô muốn nối ở đây
là cái máy trạm theo ý nghĩa lan server
ấy.
Thì cái máy trạm đang đóng vai trò là các
máy in.
Hỗ trợ của mình là cái máy nhận yêu cầu
và nó sẽ xử lý và trả về thông tin cho
máy trạm và người dùng sử dụng.
Rồi đây là các cái máy trạm thì các tiêu
chí lựa chọn thì nó cũng sẽ dựa trên các
cái nhu cầu mình cần xem xét nhưng và
mình cái việc các cái ví dụ lựa chọn,
ví dụ giống như là.
Cho văn phòng cơ bản thì mình nên đầu tư
các trạm nào phù hợp rồi những cái nhóm
kỹ nhân viên kỹ thuật, đồ họa,
kỹ thuật hoặc là các cái phòng máy đồ họa
kỹ thuật thì đòi hỏi cao hơn.
Còn phòng máy đào tạo.
Thì câu hình đồng nhất để quản lý chi phí
tối ưu cho hàng phòng máy ở trường ấy.
Thì theo tiêu chí để các em gợi ý ra thôi.
Rồi tiếp theo và các thiết bị lưu trữ thì
thường thiết bị lưu trữ là phần cứng dùng
để ghi lưu trữ và truy xuất bảo vệ dữ
liệu,
và hỗ trợ của nó là giúp lưu cái hệ điều
hành phần mềm dữ liệu vận hành, tài liệu,
hồ sơ cơ sở dữ liệu và nội dung số.
Rồi phục vụ sao lưu khôi phục và lưu trữ
lâu dài thì có ở đây khi mà nói với cái
việc lưu trữ thì các em luôn phân biệt
giữa lưu trữ cục bộ,
lưu trữ mạng và lưu trữ sao lưu hoặc là
lưu trữ dài hạn.
Thì nó có nhiều cái hỗ trợ thiết bị khác
nhau,
nhưng mà khi mà mình điều chỉnh thiết bị
thì các em cần phải phân biệt được công
nghệ ha các cái công nghệ theo công nghệ
hiện tại thì nó có 3 loại này.
Cái này cô,
nếu mà theo cái thị trường hiện tại thì
cô thấy cái này người ta không còn dùng
nhiều nha em.
Không sử dụng nhiều,
chủ yếu là mình sẽ làm theo cái này hơn
nhiều hơn và nếu mà cái nhu cầu mình cần
quản lý cao thì người ta sẽ lựa chọn các
cái mô hình kết nối như là.
HDD của HDD là mình sẽ mua thiết bị tự
quản lý luôn chứ không qua các cái dịch
vụ.
Và cái mô hình kết nối ở đây mình sẽ hình
dung hóa cái thiết bị lưu trữ của mình
không phải là chỉ là cái thiết bị mình
mua mình gắn vô máy mà nó có thể là một
cái hệ thống lưu trữ phạm vi rộng nên nó
sẽ có cái mô hình kết nối khác nhau như
là mô hình gắn trực tiếp.
Hoặc là cái mô hình lưu trữ qua mạng để
chia sẻ file hoặc là hạ tầng lưu trữ
chuyên dụng cho quy mô lớn thì các em sẽ
hiểu các thiết bị lưu trữ của mình là nó
tùy theo cái phạm vi 3 phạm vi khác nhau.
Theo mô hình thì mình sẽ thiết kế mô hình
kết nối, chứ nó không phải đơn giản là.
Việc càm em mua thêm 1 cái thiết bị lưu
trữ để gắn vô cái máy cá nhân của mình
đối với hệ thống lớn thì nó sẽ có cái mô
hình kết nối riêng và mình cần phải thiết
kế các sao cho phù hợp.
Việc.
Rồi đây cũng giống như các cái nội dung
trên thì cũng có các tiêu chí chính để
các em cần nên xem xét trong cái quá
trình mình đề xuất cái loại thiết bị và
mình giải thích.
Mình nhớ là các cái đề xuất và các thuyết
minh của mình.
Là mình không phải mình nói rồi người ta
sẽ làm theo đâu.
Mình phải đưa ra bản thiết kế,
đưa ra những giải,
đưa ra giải thích và có cái thông số rõ
ràng,
chứng minh cho sự lựa chọn của mình là
hợp lý.
Đáp ứng nhu cầu và tiết kiệm chi phí thì
nó người ta mới phù hợp hơn thì.
Đối với các thiết bị lưu trữ này,
ở đây cô có đưa ra một số cái ví dụ lựa
chọn lưu trữ để cho các em tham khảo
trong quá trình mà các em viết cái đề
xuất đầu tư của mình,
nếu mà doanh nghiệp nhỏ hoặc là doanh
nghiệp vừa,
hoặc là tổ chức lớn và trung tâm dữ liệu
thì những cái lựa chọn nào phù hợp.
Ví dụ,
giống như doanh nghiệp nhỏ thì mình chỉ
cần có một số cái máy tính SSD thôi cho
máy trạm rồi một cái next dùng chung để
lưu trữ fan nội bộ và sao lưu.
Còn cái doanh nghiệp lớn hơn thì mình sẽ
có cái.
Hệ thống server hay dùng ASUSD cho ứng
dụng HDD cho dung lượng lớn và lưu trữ dữ
liệu.
Số T là ứng dụng này cho nó sẽ biến nhanh,
còn cái này lưu trữ thì mình dùng hết DD
cũng được.
Và NAT và Store tập trung cho phòng ban,
còn lớn hơn thì đương nhiên là sử dụng
các mô hình xanh.
Rồi sao lưu nhiều lớp và dự phòng phục
hồi xa thẩm họa đối với các hệ thống lớn.
Như ngân hàng chẳng hạn,
ngân hàng mà tổ chức lớn có trung tâm
phải còn các trung tâm lưu trữ dữ liệu
nha các em.
Rồi đó là các thiết bị lưu trữ,
còn các thiết bị ngoại vi và các thiết bị
dùng để kết nối với máy tính hoặc hệ
thống để hỗ trợ nhập liệu,
sức dữ liệu tương tác và vận hành.
Vai trò của nó là mở rộng khả năng sử
dụng của hệ thống hỗ trợ làm việc,
truyền thông minh ứng,
số hóa tài liệu và trình chiếu như là các
thiết bị nhập xuất cơ bản.
Đây là một số thiết bị mà mình cần phải
có.
Nếu phải đầu tư và hỗ trợ.
Và cái này mình vẫn phải điều đó giá luôn
nha em.
Thiết bị hành vi này nó không có gì khó
giống như mình có nhu cầu sử dụng thì
mình mua bổ sung thôi.
Nhưng mà thí dụ nó sẽ tương ứng với phòng
ban vai trò và số người sử dụng.
Thường báo giá nó sẽ đi theo qua cái đó.
Rồi đây là một số cái lưu ý.
Hồi nãy cô cũng nói là khi mà các em làm
đưa ra cái.
Kế hoạch đầu tư số lượng thiết bị lõi máy
đầu tư thì mình cần nên đưa các tiêu chí
lựa chọn,
giải thích cho sự lựa chọn của mình,
cho nó hợp lý nha em.
Còn cái trung tâm dữ liệu hồi nãy tôi nói
rồi ha,
là nơi tập trung các thiết bị thường
thường là các thiết bị quan trọng như là
máy chủ, hệ thống lưu trữ thiết bị mạng,
hệ thống phụ trợ để vận hành.
Và cái này nó sẽ có cái.
Hệ thống làm mát rồi hệ thống làm mát để
đảm bảo cho cái thiết bị của mình có hoạt
động 24 trên 24 và có đồ bảo mật cao.
Ở đây là cô giới thiệu các thành phần cơ
bản,
cái này là nó nãy giờ mình hiểu các thiết
bị trên,
thì các em sẽ hiểu là các trung tâm,
trung tâm dữ liệu là nơi tập hợp mấy cái
thành ở các thiết bị trên,
những thành phần nào quan trọng.
Cho sử dụng trường chung cần bảo mật.
Cần có đội ngũ thiết bị IT hỗ trợ á thì
nó sẽ được đặt trung tâm trong cái trung
tâm dữ liệu thôi.
Chứ nó không có gì hết.
Còn cái khái niệm lưu trữ này hồi nãy,
cô có nói phía trên rồi ha các khái niệm
lưu trữ như là lưu trữ gắn trực tiếp với
máy tính,
máy chủ là đối với doanh nghiệp nhỏ này,
tại vì nó đơn giản chi phí thấp phù hợp
cá nhân, hệ thống nhỏ ha.
Còn đối với các cái hệ thống nash thì nó
có thiết bị lưu trữ,
nó phòng mạng cho phép nhiều người dùng
nhiều hơn và.
Nó phù hợp cho các doanh nghiệp vừa và
nay cô có gợi ý phía trên cái này là gợi
ý cái chia diễn giải chi tiết hơn thôi.
Còn đối với cái hệ thống xanh là trung
tâm lưu trữ chuyên dụng dành cho các
doanh nghiệp lớn và đòi hỏi bảo mật cao.
Thì người ta sẽ thiết kế theo cái hệ
thống mua chuẩn này ha,
sử dụng cái phương pháp này.
Rồi ở đó là đó là cái khái niệm cơ bản về
cái phần cứng và các cái khái niệm lưu
trữ mà các em cần biết khi cần nấm khi và
mình cần sẽ trình bày trong cái dự án đầu
tư và hay là cái thuyết minh đề tài của
mình.
Kem có chỗ nào không rõ không?
Nếu không có cho anh không rõ thì mình đi
tiếp ha thì cái tóm lại cái phần này dù
trong cái thiết bị phần cứng và thiết bị
lưu trữ thì các em nên chú ý cái nguyên
tắc lựa chọn.
À,
về cái tiêu chí lựa chọn đó ra và mình
cần biết là cái thành phần này nó liên
kết với nhau chứ nó không phải là rẹt.
Ví dụ giống như máy trạm là nơi người
dùng làm việc,
mấy chủ là nơi cung cấp dịch vụ và xử lý
tập trung.
Khi những yêu cầu từ các máy trạm và lưu
trữ là nơi dữ liệu được duy trì và bảo vệ
dùng chung.
Các thiết bị ngoại vi và các công cụ hỗ
trợ tương tác và vận hành giữa máy,
máy trạm,
máy chủ và lưu trữ ha và trung tâm dữ
liệu là môi trường tổ chức và bảo vệ toàn
bộ các hệ thống các thiết bị.
Máy chủ và các thiết bị lưu trữ quan
trọng.
Và ý nghĩa của nó là mình,
các em phải xây dựng các thiết bị làm sao
mà khi mà mình liên kết này,
nó phải có phối hợp đồng bộ giữa các
thành phần chứ nó không phải là một cái
thiết bị riêng lẻ và nó đáp.
Ứng cái nhu cầu của người cũ và tải của
hệ thống với số lượng người dùng phù hợp
và tăng trưởng trong dụng,5 năm.
Còn ở đây là một cái tình huống minh họa
này,
cô cho cái ví dụ mình có cái công doanh
nghiệp,
cái em chọn một doanh nghiệp nhỏ chỉ có
30 nhân viên, có một cái phần mềm kế toán,
có một cái hệ thống quản lý bán hàng.
Mà cái nhu cầu của họ chỉ có lưu trữ tài
liệu nội bộ và học trực tuyến đáp ứng
thường xuyên thôi thì khi đó mình gợi ý
đầu tư thiết bị đầu tiên,
đương nhiên là mình sẽ có cái trạm dành
cho 30 nhân viên này ha và chỉ có khoảng
1 đến 2 máy chủ hoặc là cái sơ.
Vượt lầu là đáp ứng cái 2 cái nhu cầu cơ
bản này.
Và cho các cái phần mềm và cái hệ thống
mà công ty này đang sử dụng.
Và này nó công ty nhỏ thôi nên mình sẽ
chọn cái hình thức lưu trữ là nash và spa
và hoặc là cái story dùng chung rồi sẽ có
cái thiết bị người vi như máy anh mạng
scan.
Time manufone biết cần thiết,
các thiết bị mạng cơ bản để kết nối các
thiết bị với nhau.
Còn cái đây tusunter thì do cái nhu cầu
phạm vi này nên không nhất thiết cần phải
có relter sinh tơ riêng,
có thể đặt server tại phòng máy chủ nhỏ
hoặc thay dịch vụ bên ngoài. Thì đó,
đây là ví dụ bên họa.
Và đương nhiên là gợi ý các thành phần
cứng mình có.
Còn khi mà các em trình bày rộng cái bài
của mình,
các em phải chọn cho cô đưa ra sự lựa
chọn mình khảo sát giá thị trường,
hệ thống các máy chủ hiện tại trong tầm
giá và nhu cầu này thường bao nhiêu.
Mấy cái hiệu nào nó từ tính đánh giá cao
chẳng hạn,
em cần phải đưa ra cái thông tin đầy đủ
hơn và đưa ra giải thích cho sự lựa chọn
của mình.
Rồi thì đó là cái nội dung của cái phần
chương 3 này các em có chỗ nào cũng rõ
luôn.
Còn nếu không phải anh không rõ thì bây
giờ cô.
Hướng dẫn khoa học bài tập mình nha.
Bài tập ngày hôm nay của mình là về xác
định phạm vi đề xuất.
Bài tập này cô mở rồi lát hồi bạn thư ký
hoặc là đại diện nhóm,
nhớ tạo folder bài tập xác định phạm vi
đề xuất và nộp linh theo hạng ngày hôm
nay nha các em.
Sau đó là các em lên bảng phân công công
việc.
Cái nhiệm vụ cho các thành viên để làm
dựa trên cái đề tài các em đăng ký ngày
hôm nay cho cô,
còn nhóm nào mà giống như hồi nãy,
giám sát,
các em cũng có khảo sát cơ bản rồi.
Thì các em chỉ cần xác định rõ hơn,
trao đổi và mình xác định rõ và cụ thể.
Phòng viên mình thực hiện.
Còn đối với nhóm 4 là nhóm 11 thì cố gắng
cập nhật nội dung đề tài trong hôm nay
xong rồi phân công công việc cho các bạn
làm để áp dụng bài tập này ha.
Thì bài tập sử dụng phạm vi đề xuất này
thì các em có thể.
Bây giờ mình vô cái phần hướng cho thực
hành ha.
Rồi các em thấy trong cái phần này đầu
tiên,
đây là nhắc lại cái phạm vi của cái đồ án
môn học của mình là để dự án đầu tư cơ sở
hạ tầng.
Và cái bước không của mình đầu tiên mình
phải xác định phạm vi đề xuất đầu tư cái
gì với mục tiêu là tránh đề xuất mua
thiết bị rời rạc và cần phải chuyển sang
đầu tư năng lực hạ tầng cho nó phù hợp để
làm cái này thì các em cần có cái khảo
sát tổng quan.
Cơ quan doanh nghiệp mà mình lựa chọn và
tôi yêu cầu cung cấp tài liệu minh chứng.
Nó có thể là cái đường link hoặc là các
cái file báo cáo hoặc là cái nội dung các
em tìm hiểu được là các em tổng hợp lại
có và có nguồn thì thường thì mình cần
phải biết lịch sử phát triển.
Của công ty đó biết được cơ bản và quy mô
và phạm vi hoạt động của công ty.
Các cơ cấu tổ chức và quy trình hoạt động
mình nào nó đang vận hành.
Lý do mình cần phải biết mấy cái này.
Tại vì trong cái hồ sơ thuyết minh đề tài
ở đây, cô đưa cho cái em.
Cái này là cô đưa gợi ý thôi,
đây là ví dụ đây là cái form thuyết minh
của mình Đại học Quốc gia.
Cô cho em biết cái form nó ra sao thôi,
chứ cái form này nó cũng thiên về phần
mềm nhiều hơn chứ nó cũng không phù hợp.
Cho với cái dự án đầu tư hạ tầng,
dự án đầu tư hạ tầng thì kem viết cái báo
cáo theo cái gửi mà cô viết trong các bạn
của nhân thực hiện này thôi.
Còn ở đây thì cô cho em cái form để các
em hình dung thôi ha.
Giả sử cái form thì thường thường một cái
form đối với Đại học Quốc gia thì.
Nó sẽ có trang bị nè,
có cái thuyết minh đề tài để mình xin
kinh phí tải nội dung ha xong rồi mình sẽ
có giải trình các khoản chi cũng giống
như hồi nãy câu nói đó em phải đưa ra các
cái khoản chi phí và mình dự toán kinh
phí theo đúng các kinh phí loại đề tài
của mình đăng ký.
Và thường cái đề tài sẽ có nhiều dòng
diệt và mỗi dòng việc người ta yêu cầu
chỉnh sửa cái gì thì mình sẽ chỉnh sửa
lại cái nội dung thí dụ người ta cần
chỉnh sửa về kinh phí để cho nói.
Ví dụ nó phải phù hợp với bảng quy định
tài chính.
Mới nhất để sau này kiểm toán tài chính
nó tới kiểm tra là mình làm đúng quy định
và có cái hồ sơ tài chính hợp lệ.
Còn nếu mà nội dung thuyết minh đầu tư
của mình có cái nào nó hợp phù hợp và hội
đồng người ta ý kiến.
Giống như bên giống như kem là khách hàng
ý kiến người ta thích cái này,
người ta qua thông qua trao đổi á thì ở
đây là hội đồng đại học quốc gia thì sau
khi có góp ý thì chỉnh sửa,
thuyết minh xong rồi thì phải có một cái
phiếu dây trình chỉnh sửa.
gì sổ.
Thường thường đối với đại học Bắc Giang
thì khoảng 4 vòng thì nó sẽ tới được sẽ
được đăng ký đề tài.
Rồi thuyết minh thì nó sẽ có ở đây nó có
2 mục.
Khi thuyết minh,
thí dụ ở đây là các thông tin cơ bản
thuyết minh thì các em cần hình dung ra
lý do cô không đưa một cái thuyết minh cụ
thể là tại vì mỗi nơi.
Vào mỗi giai đoạn nó sẽ có cái phương
thức mình khác nhau.
Nó không có cái phom nào cố định đâu các
em và do kinh nghiệm mà cô viết nhiều thì
cô biết là thí dụ cô viết muốn viết,
xin thuyết minh đề tài ở nhiều nơi và cô
quyết là khi cô viết thuyết minh thường
người ta sẽ cần có các nội dung gì?
Thì mình chuẩn bị tất cả các nội dung đó
có sẵn rồi,
cái form người ta mưu cầu điền như thế
nào thì mình điền theo form thôi.
Mình lấy nội dung của mình điền vô ha,
thí dụ nhưng mà thường mấy cái nội dung
mà người ta.
Mà
Yêu cầu đối với một cái đề tài thì nó sẽ
quanh đi qua lại mấy nội dung này thôi.
Người ta sẽ kỳ vọng em phải trình bày đầy
đủ với cái thông tin này.
Còn trình bày theo thứ tự nào,
điền vô mục nào thì thuyết minh người ta
muốn điền theo cái phần nào thì mình điền
theo phần đó rồi giả sử trong thuyết minh
người ta có cái quy định riêng chẳng hạn
có một số cái quy định riêng về phân loại
hay nhóm ngành ưu tiên chẳng hạn thì mình
phải đi coi cái quy định của nhóm ngành
ưu tiên.
Trong năm nay nó đặt cái nhóm ngành đầu
tiên như thế nào,
mã ra sao là mình vô nói chung là thuyết
minh làm đi theo quy định của bên yêu,
bên yêu cầu thôi,
nó không có phân thống nhất ở đâu.
Thí vụ đây là đại học quốc gia theo phân
này, bên Afotech của bộ khoa công nghệ.
Rằng là mua cái phương khác.
Và sẽ có ở đây cô nói luôn hả anh?
Do cái thuyết minh hay là kinh phí đầu tư,
nó sẽ thí dụ giống như ở đây á,
nó sẽ có các phòng ban liên quan cùng
nhau hỗ trợ quản lý giống như là phòng
khoa học công nghệ,
phòng quản lý các cái hồ sở chứng minh đề
tài này,
nhưng mà do cấp quốc gia nên nó sẽ có hai
phòng ban.
Khoa học công nghệ quản lý là cấp trường
và cấp đại học quốc gia rồi thêm một cái
bộ phận là quản lý tài chính để kiểm tra
cái tài chính nữa nên và có một cái hội
đồng đánh giá chuyên môn riêng.
Nên khi mà em đọc cái phom này,
cái em sẽ thấy là nó.
Nó hơi rời rạc và nó sẽ có những nội dung
bị lặp lại là do thí dụ cái rờ một không
ma đi nè các cái thông tin hiện tại em
thấy từ.
Ngoại hình thời gian thực hiện tổng chi
phí chủ nhiệm cơ quan chủ trì đối tác
nhân lực,
kết quả và mô tả sản phẩm đóng góp á thì
đây là các thông tin thường là bên phòng
khoa Công nghệ và quản lý nên người ta sẽ
yêu cầu người ta sẽ viết ở khúc đầu của
thuyết lên.
Còn bên bên cái hội đồng chuyên môn là
người ta chỉ quan tâm chuyên môn thì
người ta sẽ thường là người ta sẽ coi cái
mục b và sẽ ở trong mục b này nó sẽ có
cái bộ dung là nội dung và cái tóm tắt
công việc là nhóm người dùng công việc.
Tham gia tóm tắt bằng công việc và thành
phần, rồi ai chủ trì thực hiện cái gì?
Nó bắt buộc lại thì đôi khi nếu mà bạn
nào mà mới lần đầu quen á thì các bạn ra
cho một số bạn trẻ mới thì các bạn hay
mới mắc ở bên đây đã điền thông tin nhân
lực nghiên cứu rồi. Tại.
Qua bên đây là phải điện lại một lần nữa
thì các em phải hình dung tại cái form nó
vậy và do các bên quản lý khác nhau thì
phải điền theo thôi,
không ý kiến nhưng mà ở đây là cũng hiểu
lý do làm nhiều rồi hiểu ở đây là thường
là dành cho bên phòng họp công nghiệp
quản lý. Đây là bên quản lý chuyên môn.
Và cái mục c này là dành cho bên tài
chính.
Nên nó hay tách thành 3 file để cho 3 bộ
phần kiểm tra khác nhau thôi.
Và mình phải điền thông tin làm sao cho
cái bộ phận đọc nó dễ nhất có thể tránh
người ta đang độc này,
cái ta phải nhảy tới đi kiếm chỗ khác để
coi đủ thông tin. Nên thường người ta.
Sẽ coi một số ông tuần nữa sẽ bị lặp lại.
Rồi à,
thời đó nói về đặc điểm còn ở đây đối với
buôn của mình thì cô không có quy định
một cái form cô cho kem gợi ý các em các
cái trình bày và các em trình bày đủ các
nội dung của mình.
Trong một cái file báo cáo là được.
Và cô có gợi ý cái mục lục sẵn sẵn rồi và
khi em có thể bổ sung thêm hiệu chỉnh và
bổ sung thêm 1 luật.
Nếu cần ở đây cho mình mới làm quen nên
cô dễ ha nhưng mà nếu mà các em làm đề là
thiệt thì mình phải theo cái gu của người
ta nha không ý kiến.
Rồi lý do vì quay lại lý do vì sao mình
phải có cái lịch sử,
quy mô và cơ cấu tổ chức của trường hoạt
động thì các em hình dung trong cái mô tả
nghiên cứu, thường thường người ta hay có.
Bắt yêu cầu tính cấp thiết với tính mới
và cái này nó phải dựa trên cơ sở có
thiệt.
Thế và ý tưởng khoa học là em dựa trên
quy trình hoạt động thực tế,
dựa trên các nền tảng công nghệ thực tế,
cách thức vận hành.
Rồi dựa trên cái nhu cầu thực tế ở cái đó
là cái bên khoa học á,
bên khoa học nghệ thuật.
Còn bên thí dụ bên doanh nghiệp á hoạt
động là bên nhu cầu xã hội đang cần có
cái gì?
Và hiện trạng nó ra sao?
Và nếu mà không có nó thì đang tạo ra vấn
đề gì?
Nên chúng ta cần phải xây dựng đầu tư
hoặc là xây dựng hệ thống phần mềm này
phát triển công nghệ này.
Và khi nó phát triển công nghệ rồi,
nó đem thêm chức năng lợi ích gì và nó
mới hơn như nó mới về kỹ thuật hay là nó
với về nghiệp vụ hơn so với trước đây ra
sao để người ta thấy lý do cần thiết và
đem cái lợi ích mà người ta mang lại đó
là thường cái.
Tại vì đằng nào cũng bắt yêu cầu mình làm
cái này và các em muốn giết cái này tốt
thì các em phải có cái này.
Mình không biết công ty đó nó phát triển
quy mô ra sao?
Nó đang cần thí dụ,
thí dụ giống như trường đi cái em thành
hình dung về mình còn phải biết về lịch
sử phát triển của trường.
Nhu cầu phát triển tầm nhìn,
phát triển của trường,
thí dụ trong năm mười năm tới là muốn trở
thành trường top châu Á chẳng hạn.
Rồi có quy mô và phạm quy hoạt động,
thí dụ trong trường sẽ có các hoạt động
về giảng dạy,
hoạt động nghiên cứu rồi các cái hoạt
động hợp tác quốc tế,
học đạt hợp tác doanh nghiệp chẳng hạn
thì em phải biết các cái quy mô và hoạt
động cơ bản đó, nhu cầu thực tế.
Và các cơ cấu tổ chức là các về các quy
trình,
thí dụ đối với các quy trình nghiên cứu
khoa học thì có phòng khoa học công nghệ,
quản lý,
kết hợp với khoa phòng thí nghiệm.
Rồi phòng phải nằm viện với phòng tổ chức.
Chắc đối với các hoạt động giảng dạy như
ở trường,
ở trung tâm của mình cũng sẽ phải làm
việc với khoa và có các hoạt động giữa
giảng viên với học viên.
Và nhu cầu đó là các quy trình hoạt động
cơ bản và.
Cái nhu cầu thí dụ theo cái nhu cầu hoạt
động học tập giữa giảng viên của sinh
viên hiện tại đi thì nó có một cái số vấn
đề lại mình còn hiểu cái này để mình biết
nó gọi là hiện trạng á.
Thì tỷ lệ rất tốt nghiệp.
Của sinh viên rất cao.
Và cái nhu cầu cái bia đặt ra thì trong
vòng 5 năm tới tăng khả năng tốt nghiệp
đúng hạn của sinh viên lên 75% chẳng hạn.
Tại vì thường các trường của mình mà tỷ
lệ tốt nghiệp mà bị nó thấp và tỷ lệ sinh
viên bị đuổi cũng cao lắm nha.
Nếu mà tính gọi là đúng hạn 30%,
em cứ hình dung là khoảng 100 bạn thì 30
bạn sinh viên tốt nghiệp đúng hạn.
Còn sao thì còn lại rơi rớt,
mấy bạn rơi rớt ra thêm 2 năm nữa,
có bạn thì cũng ráng lớp qua được 2 năm,
qua được 2 năm rồi mình cũng tốt nghiệp
được.
Nhưng có bạn sẽ bị đuổi luôn chẳng hạn.
Thì cái tỷ lệ đó nó sẽ khá là cao tại vì
thứ nhất là cái cách dạy bên đại học thì
yêu cầu nó sẽ cao và các bạn sẽ không còn
được quản giống như là xin cấp 3 và gần
gia đình thì có gia đình quản thúc có
sinh viên.
Có những có giáo viên.
Biểu nhiệm còn lên trên đây á thì các em
trưởng thành rồi các em ở riêng,
không có ai quản lý và các em có nhu cầu
phát triển riêng nữa và các dạng trường
thì chỉ là cố gắng học tập,
cố vấn cho các em định hình thôi.
Tại vì sẽ có những trường hợp mà các bạn.
Muốn dừng lại đi làm khoảng 1 vài năm do
điều kiện kinh tế vậy đó,
các bạn quay đại học sau đó thì đó là sự
lựa chọn chứ mình không có ép là bắt buộc
phải học đúng giống như 3 năm cấp 3 chẳng
hạn,
thì nó do có nhiều lý do nên cái tỷ lệ nó
rớt chẳng hạn và người ta muốn.
Tăng cái tỷ lệ hiện tại thì mình hay quản
lý hoạt động học tập trên thông qua các
hệ thống inalin hoặc là có e-in,
hoặc cái hệ thống kho của trường chẳng
hạn,
nhưng mà hiện tại nó chỉ dừng ở mức thống
kê, không hỗ trợ cảnh báo sớm.
Và người ta kỳ vọng, thí dụ mình muốn xây,
đó là và nếu không cảnh báo sớm thì tỷ lệ
rất tốt nghiệp cao ha, cái đó là vấn đề.
Và khi em xác định được vấn đề của cái
quy trình hoạt động ở công ty đó rồi thì
bây giờ mình đưa ra tính cấp thiết.
Bây giờ có các công nghệ mới như là công
nghệ ứng dụng trí tuệ nhân tạo, hỗ trợ,
dự báo sớm cảnh báo sớm,
chẳng hạn giống như mình cảnh báo sớm khả
năng rất tốt nghiệp của sinh viên để hỗ
trợ cố vấn học tập, tư vấn tốt hơn.
Tại vì bình thường bây giờ là cố vấn học
tập,
chỉ có thể xử lý là khi bạn đã bị cảnh
cấp.
Mũ có nghĩa là bạn đó bị học kỳ đó,
bạn đó đánh điểm bạn đó rất rất là thấp,
bị đánh rớt rồi.
Đó thì hệ thống thống kê điểm học hết môn
rồi mới có điểm thống kê ra thì cô mới
học tập mới nắm rồi mới báo cho sinh viên
báo cho phụ huynh chẳng hạn.
Nhưng mà cái đó là thường là gọi là
chuyện đã rồi,
mình chỉ có thể hỗ trợ tiếp không thì sao
cho bạn đó cố gắng học lại thôi.
Thì ở đây mình có thể ứng dụng công nghệ
trí tuệ nhân tạo mình dự báo shop,
có nghĩa là đào hộp kỳ hoặc là giữa học
kỳ theo dữ liệu học tập của các bạn đó và
đưa ra cảnh báo sớm.
À bạn này đang có khả năng tới cuối kỳ sẽ
rất nha nè,
dữ liệu học tập bạn đó bất thường chẳng
hạn,
hoặc là mình đưa ra cảnh báo tốt nghiệp
thì thí dụ sau 1 năm á thì mình có dữ
liệu hoạt động học tập và cái background
của bạn đó, giống như đầu tư.
Và bạn đó là quê quán bạn đó thi vào bằng
hình thức gì?
Cái này trước đây cô cho các cô có dạy
lớp Munitamen thì cô có xin dữ liệu UST
của trường cho các nhóm làm thử để lúc đó
các bạn có tiến hành thống kê sử liệu UIT
thử.
Cái dữ liệu về nền tảng giống như quê
quán rồi.
Trường điểm đầu vào của bạn rồi hình thức
bạn nó vào nó,
nó là cái dữ liệu thể hiện cái background
cá nhân của một bạn sinh viên kết hợp với
dữ liệu học tập của sinh viên thì có thể
dự đoán được khả năng tốt nghiệp sinh
viên sớm thể hiện.
Ví dụ giống như những bạn mà thi bằng vào
bằng đánh giá năng lực,
hoặc là các bạn đặt học sinh vào cấp quốc
gia thì và các bạn tới từ các cái vùng
tỉnh mà có cái.
Nền tảng học tập tốt á,
cái này là thiệt luôn dữ liệu thiệt luôn
á các em thì khả năng chơi tốt nghiệp đậu
tốt nghiệp của bạn đó, mấy bạn nó cao lắm.
Giới tính nữ nữa nha.
Giới tính nữ cũng là tốt nghiệp cao hơn
giới tính em.
Thì dựa trên những yếu tố đó,
mình tiến hành dự đoán,
thì ở đây các em có thể đặt ra được cảnh
nào, mình có thể khai thác dữ liệu đó,
xây dựng một bộ đồ AI cảnh báo sớm,
khả năng tốt nghiệp của sinh viên cho em.
Bảo cảnh báo đó là tự động gửi thông báo
về cố vấn cho phòng công tác sinh viên và
có thể báo cho phụ huynh để phụ huynh nắm
thông tin và can thiệp sớm, chẳng hạn.
Thì cái mình có thể đưa ra cái ngữ cảnh
ứng dụng đó thì ở đây là nhưng mà nếu mà
muốn để có thể miêu tả được như vậy thì
thể hiện được tính cấp thiết và tính mới
của đề tài,
cấp thiết của đây là mình giải quyết được
cái vấn đề là cảnh báo sớm.
Tính mới là em có ứng dụng công nghệ mới.
Cứ nghĩ ai để họ vào cái quy trình hoạt
động cố vấn học tập bình thường,
chẳng hạn thì em muốn miêu tả được một
cái chi tiết cơ bản mà rõ ràng như vậy
thì em phải ít nhất phải nắm được mấy cái
thông tin cơ bản này.
Mình không cần hiểu quá rõ về các thông
tin hay là em thanh tra công ty đó cũng
không yêu cầu em thanh tra, nhắc lại nha,
không cần thanh tra công ty đó đâu,
doanh nghiệp đó đâu mà các em chỉ cần nắm
các thông tin cơ bản và các vấn đề của
công ty đó để đặt ra ngữ cảnh thì khi lúc
đó cái.
Em miêu tả để tạo hình thức cấp thiết
tính mới đề tài, nó sẽ hay hơn.
Tối nay em hình dung không,
nếu nào thêm kịp thì báo cô ha.
Rồi tiếp theo thì.
Năm lớp năng lực.
Hồi nãy sửa bài cho nhóm,
sửa bài thì cô có ý rồi. Năm lớp năng lực.
Ở đây mình mở cái này lên cho các em dễ
hình dung á.
Rồi bài tập trước 2.
Rồi đây là cái 5 lớp năng lực của mình.
Rồi anh cô có nói.
Nhắc lại là năm lớp năng lực.
5 thành phần.
Cho em kem lựa chọn.
Cho các em chọn một hoặc kết hợp các nhóm
có nghĩa là các em hồi nay cô nói là cho
các em có thể chọn một lớp giống như lớp
data platform không,
hoặc là hồi nay có thấy có một vài nhóm
đăng ký là data platform nè,
security và up platform chẳng hạn.
Tùy theo em chọn.
Chẳng quay chậm cả 1 hoặc là 3 2 3 lớp gì
đó,
nhưng mà hạn chế chọn 5 thì 5 nhiều quá,
các em không có làm hết đâu.
Mình chọn vừa phải,
mình nghiên cứu sau nó sai hơn.
Ở rồi,
còn các thành phần thì các em cũng có thể
có quyền giả lập là thí dụ ở phần cứng
với lại cái mạng.
Ở hai cái này,
nó không có liên quan nhiều về cái ngành
công chuyên ngành của mình nên các em có
thể gia đọc phần cứng với mạng và giả sử
nó đáp ứng đủ nhu cầu của người dùng rồi,
bây giờ mình muốn đầu tư 3 lớp này và
mình chỉ đầu tư hạ tầng phần mềm và về và
cái phần công nghệ, vấn đề bảo mật thôi.
Cái đó là kem của quyền sự lựa chọn của
mình luôn nha kem.
Nhưng mà cái nào cũng có giá của nó,
ha là của nó rồi ha.
Phạm vi chọn vừa phải,
còn nhóm nào mà các em chọn ít quá mà nó
thì nó giống như là các em đưa ra dự án
đầu tư.
Câu muốn nói và câu đến chấm điểm của em
giống như dễ đầu tư á dự án em hay thì em
xin được kinh phí cao.
Còn dự án em ít quá,
nó không có tầm ảnh hưởng,
nó không đủ lớn thì kinh phí em thấp,
nghĩa là điểm em thấp.
Nhưng mà cái điều đó không có vô trọng
quá nhiều nha,
vừa đủ mà nó đầy đủ thông tin á cái nào
lớn quá thì thường giống như cô cũng hay
nhận.
Nếu mà đưa ra một cái phạm vi đề tài lớn
quá thì hội đồng sẽ nói đề tài rộng quá,
nó không có vô trọng tâm.
Còn cái nào đó đề nghị giảm,
xác định rõ cái phần viên đề tài và các
nhóm năng lực mình muốn phát triển,
ví dụ như vậy ha.
Rồi đó là cái mục tiêu,
nội dung số a bước 0 và kỳ vọng đầu ra là
các em sẽ có một cái miêu tả ngắn gọn về
sự lựa chọn.
Em muốn đầu tư lớp năng lực nào?
Cho đối tượng nào và trong bao lâu đối
tượng nó như hồi nãy cô nói này nhưng
nhân viên phòng ban quy trình hoạt động
nào?
Cái ví dụ của nó nãy giờ là quy trình
giảng dạy giữa giảng viên và sinh viên.
Thành phần tham gia là giảng viên của
sinh viên ha rồi bao lâu thì của hãng
định kỳ 5 năm chẳng hạn,
chu kỳ thường các dự án phát triển kỳ
vọng nó sẽ hoạt động ổn định trong khoảng
5 năm.
Rồi đó là cái yêu cầu phần bài tập này.
Các nhóm có chỗ này không đỏ hơn kem.
Bạn.
Sao đây.
Dạ,
cô cho em hỏi mình có 5 lớp năng lực là
B.
mình có 5 lớp năng lực. Nếu mà bên em,
bên nhóm em đi cả 5 lớp nhân lực,
lớp năng lực nhưng bên em chỉ đi tập
trung vào phần mềm quản.
Thì và bảo mật thì OK đột mà đúng chưa cô?
Rồi cái đó cô cho các em chọn.
Vậy là mình có thể lựa chọn năng lực nào
cũng được và đi sâu về lần nào cũng được,
đúng không cô?
Ừ nhưng mà làm cái khuyết điểm của cô á
là đừng đi hết nguyên cái bảng này nha
các em,
ví dụ giống như em chọn 5 lớp năng lực và
các em chỉ đi vô phần mềm với cái phần
quản trị bảo mật thôi thì các em chỉ có
một cột 2 cột.
Qua cậu này cũng được,
nó không có nó vừa đủ.
Chứ đừng nên làm ngồi làm hết tất cả các
ô này giống như sự lựa chọn của các em là
em sẽ còn các cô các em **** muốn đầu tư
nó vừa vừa thì nó sẽ ổn.
Còn các em làm hết á,
thì nó lớn quá mà các em không có,
chưa có đủ kinh nghiệm và.
Có những cái phần nó không phải chuyên
ngành của mình đó,
các em phân tích không có sâu thì nó cũng
không có hay ha.
Dạ dạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Được.
Nh 4
Cái bóng tính thông tin biết cách chọn
không em.
Dạ dạ tụi em biết cái cô nhưng mà tụi em
lát nữa tụi em biết tin tụi em chọn lại.
Ừ
Thì cũng đang có những option đó.
Ừ, nó đăng ký đề tài chọn lại như em.
Ch chà.
Nếu 11 kem, nó thông tin chưa?
Tụi em có đăng ký trên tin nhắn rồi đó cô.
Tin nhắn nào là bài post hả em?
Là cái boss này.
Dạ không,
trong cái tin nhắn mà cô đăng đề tài.
Đó là phải bóp xem trước qua tin nhắn cái
bóp này đúng không?
Bệnh viện Đại học Bây giờ thành phố Hồ
Chí Minh đúng không?
Dạ đúng rồi ạ.
Rồi anh viên đại học Y Dục.
Dạ, cô cập nhật cho em vô nhóm 11 luôn.
Cô em thấy bên cái phần danh sách chưa có
cập nhật, em sẽ nhóm 11.
Em tin gì?
Nhiệm vụ và Vũ Đức Quang Vinh số 123
không?
Nếu 11 là em,
nếu mà mở ra xét nhận hành viên này phải
không các em?
Dạ đúng rồi cô.
Dạ, em cảm ơn cô.
Rồi con cập nhật ra.
Cô cô em nhờ em đổi lại nhóm trưởng.
Đã khoan khoan.
Nhóm 11 đây là 9 thành viên,
nhóm nào đội nhóm trưởng em?
Ở nhóm nhóm 7.
Bạn nào làm giám trưởng?
Nhâm nhân 4 nhân 4 luôn nhưng 3 chứ.
Hiệp 3 đổi lại đạt làm tưởng.
Rồi.
Bạn hoàng phương.
Dạ ơn.
Mà còn nhóm nào có muốn đổi thông tin nữa
không em?
Mấy bạn này hôm nay có đi học không?
Không đi học chắc không có rồi,
nếu không có vấn đề gì thì các nhóm.
Rồi đây cô coi còn tác gì chưa giao không
ta, bài tập về nhà, ok và nhà vậy thôi.
Vậy bài tập về nhà tuần này của các em
nhớ.
Nạp đường link trước hết em rồi các em
phải chọn đề tài nên chọn đề tài và xác
định cái theo cái đăng ký ipod nó cụ thể
rồi các em thực hiện khá bước không cho
cái đầu bài vô học của mình.
Theo cái phạm vi đề tài mà các em đã chọn.
Nhất là có 1 tuần trao đổi kỹ để chọn kỹ
nha em.
Ờ mình chọn cái thí dụ cái mấy bước này
là cái là cái bước mà nó quyết định cho
các em làm cái phạm vi,
cái đề tài của mình khảo sát và đưa lên
đề xuất dự án trong cho các bước tiếp
theo nội dung tiếp theo.
Nên cái chỗ này mà nếu mà kem thay đổi
thì sau này nó làm kem phải cập nhật lại
hết từ trên xuống dưới nên nhóm lên trao
đổi kỹ và làm kỹ cái phần này á kem.
Rồi nếu mà không có câu hỏi nào đặt ra
rồi thì buổi học mình sẽ kết thúc ở đây
nha Kim.
Là mày game.